i we have uh two subs today
uh
representative schultz
and representative long
do you have those mr clerk okay great
thank you
what i'm planning to do
is that after we go through each
division's bills
i'm going to take
a 10 minute recess
so that we can
get
janet
allow her to
do her thing
and
with the correct information
and uh so that she's not here
till nine o'clock tonight
trying to uh
trying to get um
all of our
reports
together and the votes and all that
other stuff so
um
i think that will
help her
and help me
and it doesn't look like we have too
many
minority reports so that's
not a bad thing
okay um
uh sb
telling you i have gotten dyslexic all
sb267 thank you
i will call
i will call on representative embrack
thank you madam chair i would look to
representative griffin to make a motion
madam chair i move
on to pass on senate bill
of 267 fna no i don't think that's what
you want to do
i think you want to make a motion to
accept
amendment i'm sorry
my mistake
that's quite all right
i apologize there is an amendment
um man of cheryl make a motion to accept
the amendment
do i have a second
second
hatch oh i'm sorry
so madam chair the the amendment number
wasn't read in the motion i assume it is
one seven seven nine is that a good
okay
uh represent griffin do you want to
speak to your motion
uh yes
uh this bill uh appropriates a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for the
reimbursement of municipalities
for their purchase of uh herbicides now
you're talking about the amendment
amendment to the bill sets out the
method
and timing of such reimbursements
and the amendment also requires a
department to maintain
an active invasive species
remediation program
of mechanical
cultural
biological and chemical controls
to prevent the spread of invasive
species all right i think we're con
i think we're confusing the amendment
and the bill i think you're talking
the amendment says
we have a in
active upland invasive species program
and then
subsidize the purchase of herbicides by
municipality
the amendment reduces the need to have
bulk purchases
because the department couldn't maintain
purchasing in bulk that's the primary
change on the amendment okay thank you
so all those in favor of amendment uh 22
opposed
representative griffin now could i have
an octopass as amended
yes madam chair
i move on to pass as amended on senate
bill
267 fna okay
thank you
uh
would you like to speak oh do i have a
second
where'd that
mooney okay thank you
yeah
would you like to uh say anything else
about
this bill
the bill establishes a position of
upland invasive species program
coordinator
in the department of agriculture
markets and food
the bill also establishes upland
invasive
species remediation program
and fund and it makes an appropriation
okay i think i covered the amendment
which is the rest of the bill all right
are there any questions for
representative griffin
seeing none will the clerk please call
thank you madam chair
uh representative weiler yes
representative
yes representative petry votes yes
representative emrick yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative lynn yes representative
mooney yes representative turcotte yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
arizona walls
yes
representative heath yes
representative murray
yes representative schultz yes there's
an umbrella
yes
madam
chair the vote is on sb 267
is uh
21-0 any affirmative
thank you
um
[Music]
sb 267
yes regular calendar
i don't see anything on here that we can
so
yeah
uh
sb 303
uh representative emmerich
thank you madam chair i refer to
representative representative griffin
this time to make a motion
madam chair i'd like to uh move utter
pass on sb 303. fn
second
would you like to comment on your bill
on this
on your motion thank you madam chair
this bill requires a judicial branch
to reimburse the sheriff's office
at a rate provided in the collective
bargaining agreement
applicable to per diem court security
officers
for court security
and prisoner custody and control
the obligation to reimburse the
sheriff's office for court security and
prison
custody and control shifted in
2021 from the department of
administrative services to the judicial
branch
currently court security officers are
paid at a rate provided in the
collective
bargaining agreement this bill brings
the reimbursement of the sheriffs
in line with that collective bargaining
agreement
and should help with the recruitment and
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role thank you very much
uh representative wilder yes
president burris yes president of petrie
votes yes representative emerick yes
representative erf yes representative
griffin
yes represent edwards yes arizona bean
yeah representative lynn yes
representative booney
yes arizona turcotte yes
arizona walner yes
representative norgren yes there's an
abuco yes represent long yes
representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes representative schultz yes it
was an umbrella
yes
madam chair the vote is 21-0 on sb-303
sb 303
on it
is octopass on a 21
to zero vote
we'll now turn to sb 363
and i'll call on
representative emmerich thank you madam
chair i would ask representative griffin
madam chair i move out to pass
on senate bill 36 c3 fn
do i have a second
representative griffin do you want to
speak to your motion
thank you madam chair
this bill allows certain group two
retirement system members to purchase
non-qualified service time as credible
service
in order to reduce certain transition
provision requirements for retirement
the pension reform bill passed in 2011
increased the service requirement for
those not yet vested by five years
this bill is aimed at that group and
allows them to buy credible service time
in order to reduce the age at which they
could retire
the bill passed a policy committee in
the full house by large majorities
the finance committee found that the
bill would have little or no cost to the
state
as those exercising this option will
bear the full
seeing none
will the clerk please call the roll the
commander chair uh arizona waller yes
representative burris yes the clerk
votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative earth yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
president bean yeah representative lynn
yes representative mooney
yes representative turcotte
yes representative walner
yes
regina norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes
president of heath yes
representative murray yes president of
schultz yes
yes madam chair of the vote on sb 363 is
21-0 in affirmative
thank you sb 363
passes otp
we now turn to sb 366.
um
i will call on uh
representative emrick
thank you madam chair i would look to
representative walls for a motion
thank you um
would you like to speak to your motion
um i'd like to give representative hatch
the ability to speak first before i do
thank
you um what this bill was intended to do
is to instill some more voter confidence
in the county system the state has with
their machines in essence what would
happen is we have over 300 polling
places in the state
which would mean over 300 machines and
they would randomly pick
two machines out of all of those to run
it against the machines that did the
calculations
during the voting night and
one of the requirements of the bill is
that they would have to be audited
within five days after the voting by the
secretary of state's office
the cost of these machines is
approximately
one hundred thousand dollars
so what we're having is a cost of a
hundred thousand dollars to
check
the validity of two
balloting machines out of all this uh
machines in the state and um
having considered that that's such a low
percentage of all the machines utilized
and and in considering that the benefit
of that against the cost is de minimis
are actually none so um
with that with the cost the extra
um
work on the secretaries of state's
office at a very busy time in a very
crunch time for that office
the majority of the
division one considered this an
expedient to legislate thank you madam
chair thank you uh represent walt you
want to whilst you want to say something
um
thank you um
the i just wanted to make clear that
this has to be done by noon on friday of
election week so it's not even quite a
full five days it's very fast and the uh
secretary of state's office was
concerned that they didn't have the time
for a proper turnaround even if this was
something that the committee thought
that it was
a speed or
smart to do
and you know two machines out of over
300 there was a suggestion that it would
intimidate people from nefarious actions
but the chances of getting caught are
less than one percent so i think it's
safe to say that this kind of minimal
uh audit would not
uh
discourage anybody who had nefarious
approach to things so again i would
concur that i think this is a waste of a
hundred thousand dollars it's not going
to do anything to secure our elections
or to even give people a sense of
security of our elections and so that's
why we opposed the purchase of this
machine
representative emerick
thank you madam chair
uh
i think it's short-sighted to decide
that we're going to buy a machine and
use it one time the intention here was
to set up a model for future auditing
and give it a trial run so to speak with
just a couple of
districts
so it's it's yes the bill itself speaks
to just the next election
however the the process
would move forward if it's if it's
effective thank you madam chair
representative mooney
thank you madam chair
i am going to oppose the motion of itl
and i would encourage my colleagues to
do the same so that i can offer can be
offered and ought to pass motion
it can be challenging amidst different
opinions different controversy related
to election law to find common ground
and cooperation and agreement however
that was found in senate bill 366
it came out of election law 20 to 0.
it was passed by the full house on
consent
it was brought to my attention earlier
today that we spend hundreds of dollars
hundreds thousands of dollars hundreds
of hours and so forth auditing state
police most recently or banks etc
why not endorse this very reasonably
priced way
to audit
elections making sure our counting
devices are working correctly
so with that i will oppose the motion i
would encourage my colleagues to do the
same and i would endorse not only the
cost of this very reasonable between
fifty and a hundred thousand to buy that
high speed speed scanner
and endorse what the election law the
full election law committee accomplished
earlier this year thank you madam chair
thank you represent mooney are there
other comments
just
i just wanted to make sure that
nobody else had their hand up okay
represent waltz um just to respond to
that i'd like to point out that the
election committee was deciding policy
it is not policy that's before this
committee it's whether it's the right
thing to do to spend a hundred thousand
dollars on these machines and the
question that we have before us is this
a wise use of money
i have said and i continue to believe it
is a waste of a hundred thousand dollars
it is not going to bring election
security or even a sense of election
security to anybody so i think that
while the election policy committee may
have supported this i think we have a
different job here and that job is to
look at the money and in looking at the
money i would suggest that this is not
an appropriate use of the money i would
also point out that this committee has
had bills like this in the past and we
have consistently turned it down finding
that these machines did not really serve
a purpose that supported us here in the
state
thank you are there any further comments
representative hatch i just have one to
the thought that this is a test run so
to speak
maybe there's some credence to that but
my thoughts are if a manufacturer is
manufacturing a machine like this
they're really
are going to speak to the accuracy of it
and the worthiness of it and often i
found in business throughout my life
something at this costly they're more
than happy to illustrate its accuracy
and its worthiness without costing
the recipients or the buyer on any money
so again i just firmly believe i'm all
for um
faith in our election system i think we
have it there is no credible evidence
evidence anywhere that what we're doing
now is not accurate and
correct so um again i just believe it's
a waste of a hundred thousand dollars
thank you madam chair
thank you for anyone else
seeing none with the clerk please call
the roll on itl
if you're in favor of itl you'll say i
if you're opposed
nay or no
thank you ma'am chair
representative weiler no
representative burris
no
representative petry votes no
representative tracy
no i'm sorry
representative emrick i it's a bad habit
still no still no
representative earth now
representative griffin no
representative edwards no
representative bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney
no
representative no
representative walner
yes
representative norgren yes
arizona buco yes representative long
yes
representative hatch yes
it was on walls yes
version of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative schultz
no
matter share the vote is 12 to 8 in the
negative
on sb
360.
i'm sure what'd they say no actually
corrected 12 to 9 in the negative
it doesn't pass okay
madam chair did you say 12 8 to 12. no
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's 12 to 9 nine in
the negative nine and
nine in favor of
itl 12 opposed so madam chair i'd like
to be recognized for emotion okay just a
second the motion fails
uh representative mooney thank you i'd
like to move ought to pass on senate
will the clerk please call the roll
all right let's try this again
thank you madam chair
uh representative wilder
this is all to pass
i vote yes or not to pass thank you
rejecter burrish
yes
president petry volchias representative
emerick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative bean
representative lynn yes or was it a
mooney
yes there's enough yes
representative walner
no
represent an organ
no no all right you only get one
representative
no
representative long no
representative hatch no
president of walls no regional heath no
arizona murray no
representative schultz no
representative umberger
yes
madam chair there are 12 yays and nine
no's on autopass on 360 sb 366. okay can
someone tell me who's doing the minority
report
okay
okay we now turn to sb
relative to verification of voter
affidavits
representative emrick madam chair i'd
like to representative rep
recognize representative lynn for an
amendment
i think he's got it for you
you know madam chairs is this the
appropriate time for the amendment or
should we deal with the the
the itl motion first i whatever you
prefer
uh yeah i think we need to uh
it's currently in um
interim study
and i'm chairman i'd be happy to make a
motion for interim study because that's
what i was planning on doing yeah that's
that's correct
okay so are you accept are you accepting
my motion for interim study
yes i am and i think representative
i think that probably needs to be
seconded
yes it does
okay
who did that
okay thank you
so well shh would you like me to speak
to my motion or would we are we
considering an amendment in just a
okay now represent waltz would you like
to speak to your motion i would
thank you
so
this bill the reason the committee went
for interim study is this bill is a
troubled bill
and it puts us in violation of a number
of things if we actually pass this bill
as it came for us recognizing that there
may be some concerns we thought we might
go to interim study and the first thing
we need to consider is the uniform and
overseas citizens absentee voting act
and that act says that we have to send
to military people their ballots 45 days
before the election and this applies not
just to the members of the military but
to anybody voting overseas us government
employees or american citizens living
overseas
the way this bill would work is you
could not certify the vote until 14 days
after the election
given the timing of our primary
it would not allow for certification in
time to meet that 45-day requirement to
send the ballots to any overseas voter
so it would immediately put us in
violation of
uocaba
it also would make it possible
for local election officials um
let me let me repeat my i'm repeating
myself here
um
it would also put us in violation um or
a problem with the national voter
registration act which is because we are
subject to that because we have same-day
voter registration
and if we're in violation of that it's
going to really complicate all kinds of
future registrations in this state and
we would all of a sudden have to set up
a whole new voter registration system
inconsistent with what we currently have
that would be expensive to say the least
finally we all have gotten a lot of
emails on this because what it does is
that violates voter addonimity um in
other words the secret ballot would no
longer exist for certain people um and
so that it would set up what's called
provisional ballots where ballots would
be marked and they would be able to
trace back to the actual voter
so
for those reasons i want to say that we
oppose it because it
and i just want to say too i think every
veteran every member of the military
should be voting against this because
you're really disenfranchising our
military members who are outside the
country
and i think it's wrong to disenfranchise
our overseas voters but in particular
our military members and anybody who's a
vet in this room i think they understand
it i'm sure many of you have voted from
overseas
i know i have
and so i would say we should not be
disenfranchising our overseas voters we
don't want to risk being a violation of
federal law in particular we don't want
to take away the secret ballot we have a
long history of secret ballot in this
country and why would we want to go
there for all those things i think it
makes more sense to go to interim study
and to look at how we can meet the needs
of people's concerns about voter
registration without violating federal
law and without violating individual
rights and without violating
thank you very much
representative emrick
thank you madam chair
one of the things that's very
interesting about this argument is that
we're violating uh
uh privacy
we don't know who the individual is
because they have no id
so i don't really think we're violating
anybody's privacy because they haven't
identified themselves yet
as far as the
foreign
ballots
the timing issue will have to be
addressed
and the
concept of having an id
to vote
is supported by this bill
thank you madam chair
are there any other
comments
thank you madam chair i am going to
oppose the amend excuse me the motion
of interim study and i would encourage
my colleagues to also oppose it so that
a motion of ought to pass can be made
now this bill came to finance after a
vote in the full house of 180 to 154 in
favor of ought to pass with amendment
now the house amendment
allows the bill to only apply to those
registering for the first time on
election day without proof of his or her
identity the intention of the bill is to
strengthen election integrity and
improve the verification
of voter identification and residency
interestingly enough it came to light
that
733 individuals state wide
in the general election of 2020
voted without showing an id so they then
had to fill out an affidavit now it's
unknown how many of those
were registering for the first time to
vote same-day voter registration but we
were assured yesterday by a
representative from the secretary of
state's office would be a lot less than
perhaps it could be just a couple
hundred so that's uh what we're talking
in terms of numbers uh i would believe
that the spending an estimated uh 48 000
in fiscal year 2023 and then 72 000 in
fiscal year 2025
would be certainly reasonable in terms
of verifying voter identity for same day
voter
registrants
that being said you know with regards to
to veterans i've seen the ads i've seen
the um there was a handout yesterday
given to us in division one
but i don't see a direct correlation the
way the house amended the bill to narrow
it to same-day voter registrants
also with regard to a secret ballot uh
it was
mentioned and i think worth repeating
that a secret ballot in this instance
has just as much secrecy as an absentee
ballot would have so not a whole lot has
changed other than an improved way to
verify a person is who they say they are
so for that reason i will oppose a
motion of interim study thank you madam
chair
are there any other
representative waltz
walls
thank you um to respond to a few of
these articles first of all there's a
huge distinction between marked ballots
and an absentee ballot our law
specifically says you cannot put a mark
on a ballot this is going to require
putting a specific mark on a ballot that
ties the ballot to a specific voter
unlike an absentee ballot that is
removed from the envelope in an
anonymous fashion and then cast
separately this is going to be
consistently
put separately so you can always tie the
ballot back to a voter it does not
it's not like an absentee there is no
longer an anonymous ballot for these
people when their ballots have been
marked that's one
two um
the chair of our lovely division one um
said that this will have to be dealt
with
the fact that we cannot certify on time
but the reality is if you pass this bill
there's nothing to be dealt with the
fact of the matter is if you pass this
bill if you have challenge ballots and
we may have them in many voting places
if you have any challenge ballots you
cannot possibly certify in time to get
the ballots out 45 days ahead of time it
is physically impossible so to say it
has to be dealt with to me is
meaningless how are you going to deal
with it when you have just set up a time
frame where it's absolutely impossible
to meet the requirements and mail them
within 45 days
finally i think there's nothing here the
amendment that was passed by the houses
the amendment here does nothing to solve
the problem with the military the
problem with the fact that we can't get
military ballots out within 45 days as
required by federal law continues to
exist in the bill as it exists which is
why again i think interim study is a
better approach we have huge problems
with this why are we going forward with
such a flawed bill let's study it come
back and figure out a better way to
ensure that the idea is out there and
finally i might add while we've had talk
of this we have not had to my knowledge
one prosecution in this state for for
false id or failure to provide id this
seems to me to be a solution looking for
a problem that we don't even have
evidence exists so why are we creating
more problems for ourselves violating
federal law potentially violating the
constitution for a problem that has not
even been prosecuted in this state to my
knowledge and and we know we're going to
violate the rights of our soldiers and i
think that's wrong
thank you are there further comments
this repson lin yes i i just want to say
i i have to say with due respect to the
representative who just spoke i i
honestly do not understand the
difference that she's trying to draw
between an absentee ballot in terms of
knowing the identity and and a ballot
that would be a provisional ballot
absentee ballot somebody opens the
envelope they know who it's from they
see the name so somebody in the election
hierarchy so to speak knows who the
voter is that would be the same thing
here um it's uh those people are
are required to keep the matter
confidential there's no um i'm not i
just don't uh
see the distinction and as i understand
i was not present in the in the uh uh
election law when when uh this part of
the bill was was this this issue was
discussed but it's my understanding that
the that it is possible to uh
to complete this within the time
required under the uh
uh for the to comply with the overseas
representing walls
a quick response
representative lynn the difference is
that the ballots are marked
once you mark the ballot it is forever
identifiable with that voter absentee
ballots are never marked so maybe the
person who opens the envelope chooses to
glance at the ballot and see how they
vote but they're going to be the only
person that knows the minute you mark
that ballot everybody who handles that
ballot henceforth can tie that back to
that voter and henceforth that voter has
lost all anonymity that's the difference
okay if you would like me to explain on
the calendar how we don't meet the the
days i would be happy to do it i've got
the dates in front of me of how this
can't work um but
we do not have
with with the september 10th primary
date and the ballots must be sent out
september 21st
we are going to have issues on these
years some years with our primary
meeting this deadline we are not going
to be able to get the ballots out in
time remember after certification they
still have to be printed and to get them
certified and and then printed and
mailed we're not going to be able to
thank you
sir further representative schultz
thank you madam chair i just want to
clarify because i didn't understand
initially what was meant by saying
marked the ballot this means specific to
each ballot for example
uh and this was from the working group
and an official from the
secretary of state's office attested to
this
that each individual ballot in this
category would be marked for example the
first one could be
voter number one like literally on the
ballot
would be marked in that fashion
the next one would be
ballot number two so beyond the signing
of an envelope the actual ballot itself
that's what uh the representative means
by the ballot is marked
thank you
the seeing none will the clerk please
call the roll
the vote is
or the the motion is
uh interim study
yes thank you madam chair uh this is uh
senate bill 418. yes sorry
uh
representative weiler
no
representative burris
representative petrie votes no
representative emrick no
representative earth no
representative griffin no
representative edwards no representative
bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney no
roberto no
representative walner yes
representing auburn yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch absolutely yes
arizona walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes representative schultz yes
representative burger
no
bannon shearer the vote is on sb 418 is
nine nos uh nine yays and twelve no's
the motion fails okay that was for
interim study
uh
yes is there someone that represents
i'll call on you
oh yes i'll
recognize representative griffin for a
motion
madam chair
um
i move senate bill
418 fn ought to pass
second
a question to the chair just a moment it
was seconded by uh mooney or or i'm
sorry true kirchhoff arizona
okay that's griffin yes we have an
amendment what is your question
represent edward you just asked answered
representative
okay
no
i will call on representative lynn
who has a
minor change to the bill
thank you
for
an amendment i would move amendment um
1870h which i believe was just
distributed to everyone it is literally
this the
just the moment
second
thank you
would you like to be yes if i speak to
him i'm sorry
um i would move i would like to speak to
the amendment it it makes the most minor
technical change i discovered in proof
reading the bill that there was a
discrepancy between on page two of the
original bill line 12 refers to 10 days
line 22 refers to seven days they should
both be seven days that's what this
amendment accomplishes and that's all so
i would move uh the amendment i would
we've already we've already moved the
amendment
okay all those in favor of amendment
2022 1870
oh one two three four five six seven
twelve in favor
nine opposed
the amendment passes who was uh who's
the second on that uh uh represent
okay are there any further comments on
[Music]
uh
sb 418
otpa
who's the
who made the motion
oh i thought i didn't have an odp
okay uh representative emerick uh moves
otpa
second for set 418 and seconded by
representative mooney i'm sorry i
thought i had a
otpa
all right
well the clerk
please call the roll
thank you madam chair
oh this is on
418. senate bill 418
otpa
representative waller yes
representative burris yes
president petry vocias representative
emmerich yes representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yes represent flynn
yes
representative mooney yes president
turcotte yes
representative walner no
representative norburn no
representative bucco no representative
long no
representative hatch no
representative walsh on behalf of our
overseas and military voters absolutely
no
heath no
roger murray no
representative schultz
new
representative burger yeah
i'm sure there are 12 years
the motion passes okay
uh
yeah who is going to do the minority
report
part i'm sorry
okay make sure you turn your mic on so i
can hear you
i'll get it to your hatch okay thank you
okay
and the majority report
representative griffin's going to do
them i'm sorry
okay thank you
is there going to be a minority report
yes
and that's
the minority report on 418 is
and the minority report on
366 is false is waltz 360s
okay
and i didn't get who was doing the uh
yeah
well that represent
okay thank you
uh we now turn to
sb 3 438
establishing state procurement policies
intended to promote the use of american
materials
representative emrick
thank you madam chair i would look to
madam chair i move
onto pass on sb
do i have a second
representative to bear seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair
this bill requires the use of
american-made steel products in all
public work projects
where the state administers the contract
and the contract involves
at least a million dollars
a million state dollars
the finance committee heard testimony
from local new hampshire steel
fabricators
who told us about the uneven playing
field
they are forced to compete went in
with foreign steel flowing through a
heavily subsidized
canadian steel fabrication industry
we also heard their testimony
on the
on the economic
aspects
of of
locally produced steel
keeping the dollars at home has a
multiple effect
where if we send the dollars to a
foreign country
we have no multiple effect at last
forever
the committee also feels that a healthy
steel industry
is very important to our state
and our country from a national defense
standpoint
therefore the division one voted
to recommend not to pass
thank you are there any further comments
representative
thank you madam chair
i'm going to rise in opposition to this
bill and hopefully by the end of my
short speech i will have some of you
on board with what i'm about to say
as legislators we are the
stewards of taxpayer dollars and
especially this committee being the
finance committee we've even got a a
greater
requirement to be good stewards
there's no doubt that
this bill
will increase stock costs to state
projects
we heard during testimonies that
estimate it could be estimated between
20 25 percent
and what's also was not considered and
we heard from representative growing
firmer senator gruen
that um delays
he's in the business he said he could
expect delays up to a year so not only
do
would we have increased
costs but we would have delays
now there are two bills one that's
already passed this body and one that we
will be discussing later
where we we are going to spend 35
and 36 million dollars respectively one
on a new parking garage for
the state legislator
legislature and one that we're going to
send 36 million dollars out for bridges
now
35 million garage a good percentage of
that garage is going to be structural
steel and it's going to be pre-stressed
concrete
preset pre-stressed concrete uses iron
in the concrete itself so what is going
to be the increased cost for that 35
million dollar state garage
that the taxpayers are going to have to
the steel industry it's not the first
time we've seen this
type of
problem
we've seen it in the past with lumber
we've seen it in the past with computer
chips
on and on and on this is a federal issue
this isn't something that we at the
attempting to solve it's a much bigger
issue that should be handled on the on
the on the federal level
um
you know and like i say we we've had
this issue with lumber computer chips in
the past are we going to after we pass
this are we going to start requiring
other procr
procurements for other types of things
easy example airlines are we going to
require all our state people to
ride on an american airline to
toronto not only will the cost be higher
but you're going to add in
inconveniences such as instead of going
directly from boston to toronto you get
on a plane from boston go south an hour
to philly and then backtrack up to
toronto but
we'd be
giving the american airline industry a a
good boost i don't agree with that
now i'm going to give you a final
analogy and i ask you to consider this
analogy because it's very um
illustrative of i think our situation
you decide you're going to get a house
built and you hire a contractor
and the contractor comes to you and says
okay here's the deal i can build your
house
for three hundred thousand dollars
and i can start in two months
however if you want to use all u s
materials
it's gonna cost you an extra twenty
thousand so that bill would now be three
hundred and sixty thousand dollars
oh and because of a lot of the materials
i can't get immediately we could have
delays up to a year
now if you can honestly say to yourself
that yes i would pay that three hundred
sixty thousand dollars rather rather
than the 300 000 for that house because
you want to keep your money local
then you should vote on this bill if you
can honestly say that i don't believe
you can
uh
if you can't if if if you can't be
good stewards of your own money
personally at least here in the state
i will say that i sympathize with the
steel industry it's it's not lost on me
but i just can't
i can't vote for something that will
increase the cost to state projects by
20 to 25
percent we do have to be good stewards
of our taxpayers money thank you madam
chair
thank you representative representative
hatch
yes uh thank you madam chair if i may i
just a
query with the last speaker
um
you're throwing out figures you're using
25 percent and you're talking about
increased cost and in fact you gave an
analogy that used was exactly 20
of the whole project cost over um using
say
uh local products or american-made
products or whatever the analogy said
i really need to know what those figures
are based on because i i'm not sure i
agree
that the steel in a project
is um
more than much than ten percent
of the total cost of the project um
that's one thing it there's variables of
course a steel bridge that's different
but um your general construction um
figures it's usually around a 10 factor
um and then um to come up with exact
figures where where did you
what did you base those out or where are
you getting those figures from and
that's the sincere question the 20 to 25
thank you madam chair uh the 20-25 were
numbers that i uh heard during testimony
um and what i will say about your 10 10
costs i i will still draw the same
analogy
granted your house doesn't contain a
heck of a lot of steel but the idea is
not to talk about steel in that analogy
but the costs involved so let's go to
your 10
number
if the contractor comes to you and says
300 000 or 330 000 if we use all us
materials
um are you still willing to pay that 30
extra thousand and if you aren't then
you shouldn't be willing to spend the
taxpayers extra money when when we don't
have to
thank you madam chair
thank you are there representatives yeah
thank you madam chairman um
the bill before us deals with uh steel
and leveling the the
playing field between canada and the
united states
the one of the previous speakers
asserted or assumes that
future procurement that we're setting a
precedent
for other materials that would be
skyrocketed and we could control of you
know and whatnot so i disagree
the bill is just dealing with
steel and not future acquisitions of
thank you are there any further comments
represent emrick thank you madam chair i
i believe if you read the bill you'll
also find that the
it does not afford a provider
extended delays
uh or excessive costs
the example that was given during
testimony
seven million dollar
steal quote that was five hundred
thousand dollars
more than what the canadian bid was so
it's not a twenty we're not talking
twenty percent necessarily so i would
just
caution that
a decision maker
here at the state in the department of
administrative services will look at
timely delivery and cost thank you madam
chair thank you are there any
representative edwards
uh madam chair i'm i'm deeply conflicted
about the vote on this bill um because
uh i am a big believer in
free markets and the inability of
government at any level
to effectively intervene into the
marketplace and do so effectively and
without unintended consequences
so so that would suggest i would vote no
on the other hand um
i'm i'm taking a look at a situation
where i i think for decades we've had a
lack of national leadership when it came
to treating our trading partners in a
way that would respect the american
worker and i don't mean the current
administration i mean many many many
administrations have failed to protect
the american worker so that would
suggest i'd vote yes
so i i don't really know how i'm gonna
vote but uh but i i just i don't think
thank you
anything any further comments
represent petrie right thank you madam
chair uh one of the things you might
think about is
money has velocity you keep the gdp
within the state
uh that velocity is four to six times i
think is naturally used and that's
that's pretty important uh because once
it's gone out of the state it's gone
thank you
is there anything else on this
seeing nothing uh will the clerk please
call the roll
this is uh
motion is um
ought to pass on sb 438
thank you madam chair
representative weiler yes
president
yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf now
no
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
arizona hatch yes
version of walls yes
president of heath yes
representatives uh murray yes
representative schultz
yes
representative hamburger
i'm sure there are 18 yeses and three
no's for sb 438 on autopass okay
sb 438
uh
has a vote of 18 to 3 for
otp we now move to estimate madam chair
oh it's i'm sorry minority report there
what will the minority report
i'm not in the consent calendar you
can't put it on the concept no no why
okay
all right we now turn to sb
uh 443
relative to municipal authority
regarding the state building codes
um
representative i call on representative
emrick thank you madam chair i would
look to representative griffin for a
motion
madam chair i um move out to pass on sb
443 fm do i have a second
second
second by representative emrick
would you like to speak to your most in
motion representative griffin thank you
madam chair
this bill provides that the building
code review board
shall review proposed municipal
amendments to the state building code
and to confirm that the pros amendments
do not conflict with
and are no less stringent than the state
building code
and it requires submission of local
amendments prior to enforcement
the bill also requires a state fire
marshal to review local amendments
to the state fire code prior to
enforcement
and to publish local amendments to the
state fire code
the finance committee heard testimony
that this bill makes much needed changes
to several sections of rsa 155
by requiring
local changes to this
to the state adopted building and fire
codes
by requiring that they would have to be
enacted as local audiences
and could not go into effect until they
were re approved by the respective state
board or the state fire marshal
the goal of the bill is to end up with a
centralized place
where all local changes to codes can be
found
the effective date of this bill is
january 1st
and while the bill has no immediate
financial impact
it is anticipated that the fiscal year
24 budget
would ask for an additional full-time
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you madam chair
this is on sb 443 ought to pass
representative weiler yes
representative
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative earth yes
president griffin yes representative
edwards yes representative bean yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney
yes representative turcotte yes
rosanna walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes representative
long yes
representative hatch yes
walsh yes
president heath yes
representative murray yes
representative schultz yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair i'm happy to report that sb
443 ought to pass there's 21 years and
okay
as i said uh we were going to take a 10
minute break so janet and i can
make sure we have our stuff together
for those of you that have signed up for
minority reports
i need you to get those into janet very
shortly
and um
we'll be back at
session back to order
and i will um
represent emerick has a comment or two
and a motion
thank you madam chair uh just reviewing
what we've uh uh voted on as far as uh
consent
sp 363
has no
general funds in it it's it all it does
is allow individuals to pay down
their retirement so in essence it's
there's no
cost to the state
also
senate bill 443
relative to the municipal authority and
the state building code
the funding for that was in the next
fiscal year so it would be part of the
budget but for this fiscal year there's
there's no general funds being used so
are you making a motion so though for
both of those who are 363 and 443 to go
on consent
second thank you
is there any objection
seeing none those two bills will go on
consent
now we're gonna markup
make a mess um i'm sorry
okay
um
uh we now move to sb 346
requiring the department of defense
report
environment yeah environmental services
to conduct a feasibility and impact
study for the construction of hampton
beach
pier
and um
we have an amendment which changes the
title
which is wonderful
and it now uh is just the feasibility
and impact study for construction of a
pier
on hampton beach
so representative lynn i will ask if you
would
like to
one eight 2022183
zero
yes uh thank you madam sure if i i would
move uh okay amendment do i have a
second a second thank you representative
petrie may i speak to the uh motion you
can speak to the amendment the amendment
i'm sorry yes
uh so this amendment it uh it makes a
very simple change it just in the
original bill
had just indicated that the 150 000
appropriation was to go directly
to the hampton beach area commission
apparently um as i understand it that's
a no-no it needs to go through a state
agency so this simply provides that
the appropriation would go to the
department of natural and cultural
resources and shall be dispersed to the
hampton beach area commission that's the
extent of the amendment okay
uh are there any questions
seeing none all in favor of amendment
unanimous
representative lynn
yes i would now make a motion uh to
approve uh
do i have a second
second
what's was that represent emrick thank
you
um
would you like to speak to your motion
sure thank you madam chair
pretty much the title says the whole
thing this authorizes a feasibility
study
uh to be conducted by the hampton beach
area commission uh as to uh building a
new uh pier as i understand it the the
location is to be just
south or nor i think it's just south of
boers head in uh in hampton so uh
that's that's the bill okay are there
any further comments
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you mayor chair
uh representative weiler yes
representative burris yes
president petry votes yes representative
emerick yes
representative erf
yes
representative griffin yes president
edwards yes representative bean yes
representative lynn yes representative
mooney yes representative turcotte yes
representative walter
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes representative
is he here no no
representative walls
yes
representative heath yes
rosanna murray yes representative
schultz
yes and representative alberto yes
and i'm sure the vote on sb 346
is 20 a's
and no nays thank you very much we now
turn to
sb
relative to creating a board to review
police incidents
following citizens affected by mental
health issues
i will call on representative petry
for
a motion on amendment
number 17 28
i make that motion thank you do i have a
second
representative heath
here's the
second
okay you want to speak to your motion
yes madam chair this is uh
to uh
yeah
establish a mental health incident
review board to uh we have a lot of uh
shootings
that people are mentally ill and uh
causes a lot of
discontent obviously
and uh this is going to uh fall under
the uh
enforcement conduct review committee the
auspices of them uh
and uh to
further uh
take care of this problem uh 1.1 million
dollars is going to be appropriated for
this
and uh for cit training which is the
training officers around the state need
if you are i've already had the training
you do not need that training and uh
this will not cover it
that's all
okay this will be going to the police
okay um are there any other comments on
none all those in favor please raise
unanimous
i'll now ask uh representative petry for
a motion on sb 376. so moved
as amended ot
do i have a second
uh i'm sorry i didn't protect heath i'm
sorry i'm sorry
no
would you like to uh speak to your
motion
yeah we've already done that oh well
it's it's basically the bit that that is
the bill it's been uh amended and uh
that pretty much covers it uh
they'll be uh you know is to protect the
uh
mentally ill from uh
different things uh no it's not it's to
provide the police with well provides a
training
for the uh
well the training so they can uh deal
with these problems with mentally ill
and
uh the money provided through the
appropriation to the police standards in
training okay are there any other
comments
well the police
the police please
i got it okay well the clerk please call
the roll thank you manager we gotta have
fun
[Music]
very good uh representative wilder yes
representative burris
yes
representative petri volch yes
representative emerick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yeah representative
lynn yes representative mooney yes
president turcotte yes representative
walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative buco yes representative
long yes
representative hatch
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes rival schultz
yes representative ellenberger yes venom
chair the vote on
sb 376
is
20 to yays and no nays
the motion passes okay uh sb 376 otpa
all right
381 um
we
have amendment two zero two two
could i have a motion
don't all jump at once gang
here
representative thank you for making that
motion
good represent murray thank you for
seconding it
what's the way to handle it yes ma'am
okay
um
i will speak to this since i had to
really
arm twist out there
um
this bill
uh
wants wants to create
a um
[Music]
office
of
uh when the bill came to us
um
the
office of the
child advocacy
had authority within their
rsa
to take care of education
so we couldn't have
two people
in charge of education
and so this amendment
um
removes the
authority
from
the um
the child advocate advocate office
and um
that's what it does
this was although my name is up there
this is not my amendment it was brought
to me
by
senator reagan
and just based on what
ols has to do
ended up at the top of it
so that's
that's just the way it is
did you yes i do have a question
well yeah
in a sense nobody else wanted to talk
i guess i have questions about
didn't we just
recently um amend the av the child
advocate um
law to include oversight of um
special ed
and
doesn't it seem like it's sort of
short-sighted to all of a sudden be
taking away that authority
yes
yes we discussed that okay
and uh the education committee
and um
what was a s
senate bill 538
which was looking at all all of the
special education things
senator reagan so on
felt that
because
so different than the kinds of things
that the
child advocate was
looking at at this time
they wanted it to
to separate
speak to when
after our vote was taken
i did
remind the people from the education
committee that were there that i wanted
them to follow this very closely
and to re-look at it within a couple of
years
to see if
the special ed office belongs
in a separate
advocate office or if it should be
convul
combined
with the office of child advocate
so it's
everything you said was true but that's
basically the reason
why
this amendment
came forward and was was approved and i
will say that there were some reluctant
yeses
within division two
but we felt that it was essential that
we have something
for the
[Music]
special education
advocate
waltz
actually this is it i i do have i have
two things my first one is a question
and that is given that you want this
review does this have a sunset provision
in it to force the review no
we we did not we did not put that in um
i i just want to say i feel i feel very
strongly that uh
at least one of us will be around on
division two
in a couple of years
and
uh
they won't forget it guaranteed
so no we did not put a sunset closet
thank you
i sat on the education committee when
this bill was hurt and there was
extensive testimony
of concern that this was creating an
ineffective office where people are
going to complain to the office but
nothing's going to be able to happen
because they don't really have the staff
to address it and we're kind of just
creating something that is going to give
parents hope should we say
when
the office really is not going to be
able to do anything i mean 500 you would
need a huge office to address all the
special education
complaints in this state and 500 000 is
not establishing a huge office okay
we're talking about the amendment please
my mistake hey i just wonder if the
committee considered that yes we did
we considered everything
[Laughter]
is that correct
representable says yes okay
uh okay
seeing none all those in favor of
amendment two zero two two
one eight five seven please raise your
hand
okay let's uh let's try this again
i can't count
all those in favor of amendment 2022
okay
better be nine
yeah and keith
nine
keith earth
okay the vote was uh 12 in favor
nine opposed the amendment passes
so
now we will move to an otp a
motion for sb 381 so moved thank you
representative petry do i have a second
you want to do you want to speak to your
motion
or
do you want to just you know it's just
oh duck into the mic oh i was talking to
you actually
i'm supposed to huh no no this is uh you
know
this is the uh
advocate
okay yeah it's uh to take it out from uh
so it's independent an independent
agency under the governor
to uh look into special ed complaints
and appropriation of five hundred
thousand dollars is super
appropriate
is there any further discussion
representative heath
thank you madam chair um as i said in
committee i i really truly believe
that this position belongs
within the current
advocacy
office i think that
her role um
is critical to the state and i think it
has to involve
education and particularly special
education so i am very concerned that
we're setting up two separate offices
um we're allocating
thousand dollars um for this office for
this do i feel like it's kind of like a
duplication of efforts and i have my
okay uh represent waltz did you want to
uh actually you answered my questions
man i'm sure thank you okay thank you
thank you i just want to add that this
was very conflicting
and
for my own part i recognize the need for
this
and i think that there's a broader role
around advocacy where it would be best
served within one community
but given the situation
i was comfortable supporting it as a
separate one if we can come back to
review it and i think you're right that
we you know we will certainly be able to
do that
um
i felt that the need was pressing and so
i was comfortable with going ahead with
that
because of the need that i perceived
but i do
really feel strongly that we should
look at this again to see if it's best
as a separate office i think i share
other representatives views that perhaps
it would be better in one office where
there could be coordination and
collaboration um but it was this was a a
difficult one to to sort of suss out uh
what's what would be the best thing for
children
representative bucco did you wish to say
something
okay oh oh i'm sorry reps represent long
thank you madam chair just for
clarification the amendment removes the
office of child advocate from
education uh but in the bill i don't see
would this
advocate be responsible for education
for children that are placed out of you
know that are placed
i don't see it in here so i'm wondering
if there's this is this is for those
children
that have ieps
504s
okay
so
pardon the follow-up if i make sure so
that would be uh that would be
children and placement also oh yeah
if they have those things okay thank you
and you ain't actually
actually if i may uh say something see
the public or private i believe
public or private charter schools yeah
charter schools and private schools i
believe that's in there
so
so if i may madam chamber i'm just
children in placement there was somebody
advocating for their educational needs
if not the office child advocate it'd be
okay
anything further
i am going to vote no
because i'm really concerned about what
we do here we
we're getting children services and
silos we're going to have over here an
advocate for special education and over
we
have done a lot of work on being sure
that we had a child advocate
and that
they had
the ability to oversee
children in all settings
and now it's just splitting that apart
when we had just sort of gotten it
together where we had a really
comprehensive office
i would agree that the office probably
could certainly use
additional
person power
children's services be a special ed
be it
services for children through
protective services
and i i worried that this kind of a bill
just is starting again to put us into
silos and to split those services so i
am going to vote no on this bill thank
you
is there any further comment
seeing none
will
do it do we have an otpa
did we vote on the amendment yeah
yes we did
okay oh i should know that yeah you're
the clerk
okay
clerk please call the roll thank you
madam chair
representative weiler this is on uh
i'm sorry uh sb 381 out to pass as
amended
representative
yes president petrie votes yes
representative emerick yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
president bean
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
rosanna turcotte yes
representative
no
representative norgren no
representative long no
representative hatch no
representative walsh no
representative heath
yes
representative murray
representative schultz
yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 15 to 6 in the
affirmative for sb 381 ought to pass as
amended
okay thank you uh sb 381
uh fifth on a 15 to six vote
is recommended as otpa
is there money in this yeah
there will be a minority report and
who's writing that please yes i am okay
will it be itl the minority
um
is there money
yes
it's not like it's a huge amount
okay we now turn to sb 394
relative to the definition of a child
with disability under special education
laws
and um
we have an amendment
and i will ask
representative heath to
do i have a second
would you like to speak to uh to your
motion
uh can you pull the mic a little closer
or turn it on thank you went off um
what this amendment does is it
brings
new hampshire into compliance with
federal legislation for students 21
and
they will stay they will be able to stay
through
that school year what it also does um
is that it provides
funding for and this will be enacted um
upon passage
and what it also does is it provides
funding to school districts because
school districts will not have budgeted
for um
students who they thought would be
leaving at age 21 so we we are going we
spoke with the department and there are
remaining funds in the um
special education aid and uh as you see
within this amendment it explains the
various uh
funds that will be used to make
districts whole for this action
so i ask for your support for this
amendment thank you
are there any other comments questions
seeing none
uh
amendment
two zero two two
seven one seven seven zero if you're in
unanimous
we would work 21 again
okay
uh
i now call on representative heath
for a
ought to pass as amended motion thank
you madam chair i move
senate bill 394 as amended are to pass
as amended
seconded by representative petrie
uh would you like to speak any more on
this no i think we've covered it i think
this is is a good bill for new hampshire
it's good for school districts it's
especially good for children thank you
madam chair you're quite welcome are
seeing none
[Music]
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you very much
representative wilder
yes
president through burris yes
representative petrie vote yes
representative amrick yes
representative irf yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney
yes
representative
arizona walner
president orgrim yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
arizona walls yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes
rosanna schultz yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair of the vote on sb 334
octopass as amended is 22
1. thank you sb 394
passes
otpa and with a vote of 20 to 1.
okay we now turn to sb
making an appropriation to the
department of transportation
for local highway
to body-worn camera and dashboard camera
fund and permitting the department
of transportation to operate dash
cameras in fleet vehicles
so
we have amendment two zero two two
one eight
four four
could i please have a motion
represent featuring moves
just ahead of year i think yeah do i
have a second please a second thank you
i know but
murray raised her hand
okay all right let me see what the hell
we do here
so
yeah
the amendment um
basically replaces the entire bill
that we had
uh the first thing we did
was to
[Music]
on recommendation of dot
was to change how
the bridge money
which is
million dollars
was to be distributed to the towns
as the bill came to us it was supposed
to follow
the red list
red list bridges program
well the red list bridges program
doesn't get money out to the communities
very quickly
and it also requires a 20
match
so
the department and the committee felt
that it was important
that we
got this money out to
work on
bridges that may be red listed or
or maybe
just in need of repair
uh and again please understand this is
municipal bridges not state bridges
so i had no idea
that there were so many ways
to
to decide on how money was going to be
distributed
uh
half of the funds are going to be
distributed
based on the municipalities total bridge
deck area
okay they they actually know the
measurement of
every municipal state bridge who who
would have thought it
and then the other 18 million is going
to be distributed
based on population
and that is a common way
that dot
distributes
money at this time
the second half of the money
the the 30 million
will be um
we'll use the same appropriation as we
do in the budget for distribution of um
the 30 million
in
apportionment a for that's for roads not
for bridges
and uh this money will go to the towns
and it will be non-lapsing
so it doesn't um
it doesn't run out
because
if if you
have work to do on bridges or roads you
generally have engineering that has to
occur etc etc
so anyhow that's
that's what that part is
and then uh the body warn and dash
camera fund
we appropriated a million dollars uh to
that fund that's basically uh
no change at all
and
the final
the um
the final thing that we did is that
yesterday
we all sat through the non-germain
amendment
on uh the dixville colebrook road
project
so i don't think i need to
go through all of that
but that's what the amendment
that you're looking at and otherwise i
think it's um
it says amend the bill
other than the enacting clause so
the enacting clause
enacted okay
representative turca
thank you madam chair
i'm unfortunately and regrettably gonna
have to rise against the bill as a whole
only because of the uh project that you
mentioned yesterday that was tacked on
while i understand
the reason it was tacked on
and for those who weren't
listening to the
discussion
it
basically we are
going to
allow 4.1 million dollars to be spent to
upgrade a road that would
to
the balsams
project and or the county
towns that are involved with that
that road um
in talking about the balsams projects i
think it's kind of important that we do
discuss that because it's still
very little has been done on that to
date and
um they're still in the financing phase
there
the other thing is when you look at four
million as a percentage of the total
project
which is estimated at over 200 million
dollars you're looking at about a two
percent cost
i i believe there are
other ways um that we as the legislature
and coordination with the dot or safety
department or the attorneys or whatever
a better way and more fiscally
responsible way that we could
turn that
two-mile segment that connects the
balsam's
main hotel area with the
golf course i think there are more
fiscally responsible ways that we can
make that happen
so again for that reason
only because that was added i cannot
support the bill as a whole thank you
madam chair
thank you are there any further comments
yes
uh represent petrie yeah thank you madam
chair one of the things you i'd like to
point out is that this is a
more or less abandoned state road and
what they're gonna do is
uh or what this bill proposes is to
build it up to standards
and to give it to the town of colebrook
i believe so that's something to
weigh
in in your decision thank you
are there any further
perhaps in murray
thank you madam chair um i would just
like to put into people's minds that
looking at this just with regards to the
balsams is somewhat narrow that this is
a good economic development project that
would impact
the north country it's a fairly small
investment from our point of view but it
would have a very large impact on the
economy in the north country and so i
very much support that we're able to do
something like this to help them out
thank you thank you
representative
thank you uh bad chairman i greatly
presentation on this and his concerns
about the balsams project i just wanted
to let them know that being chair of the
delegation and when we have a meeting
with
the per the owner respective owners and
whatnot with the joint meeting with the
commissioners i will bring up that
possibility
but as the bill that i presented to you
having jumped through so many loops to
get this done
i wanted to make sure that it was iron
clad
and that not it would not spend one
penny of taxpayers money unless the
financing was there
thank you
represent turcotte yeah
one point i forgot to make
was that the
[Music]
this portion of the road um
is not contained in the
dot's 10-year plan that was brought up
at the our hearing
um both the house and the senate um
we're not in favor of including that in
the 10-year plan
um i i do understand the potential
for
um economic impact up there but as i
said the project is
still in what i would almost consider
the infancy stage
for the
dot plan or
once the project actually makes a little
more progress
that we could
readdress this situation in the future
thank you madam sure thank you
represent
thank you madam chair
um
i think it's important to understand and
i think representative tuberge alluded
to this or somebody may have that
absolutely none of this money
zero
ditto will be utilized unless the
project is in position to go forward
and that is important to know and
understand it's not like we're throwing
good money after bad money
but this road is a vital part
to this project it was once on the
10-year plan and um maybe it belongs
here again but the only reason we have
this legislation it's not there and
just remember that this is not a unheard
of
proposition
by a development we can go all over this
great land of ours in this state and
find development after development that
has had a road brought up to grade and
prior to being turned back to the
community or the state that process
takes place
it's vitally important for the north
country it's vitally important for the
uh communities and it's vitally
important for the state
that this project go forward and this
would really
benefit the likelihood of that going
forward immensely
without costing
one penny
at this point
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any further comments
seeing none could i have a show of hands
so it's uh the vote is uh
19 in favor
oh those oppo did i count wrong no
you didn't ask for a post no
because while those opposed
okay
motion of ought to pass as amended
on
representative petry moves do i have a
second second
well the uh do you want us either of you
want to speak anymore on this i think we
beat this horse dead okay
well not quite
we haven't no we did in division two but
we okay
all right
uh
will the clerk please call the roll
uh thank you madam chair all right uh
representative wyler
yes
representative burris yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative earth
no
representative griffin
yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative chircott
no
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
rosanna bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
represent walsh yes
president heath yes arizona murray yes
arizona schultz yes
madam chair the vote on sb 401 auto
passes amended is 1822.
thank you sb 401 ought to pass as
amended passes
18 to 2.
we now turn to sb 417
establishing an electric school bus
pilot program
we have amendment
to consider
could i have a motion
to accept
thank you rip some heath do i have a
second
representative murray
thank you very much
would either of you like to speak to the
motion
thank you madam chair um
uh the amendment to sb 417
provides an electric school bus pilot
program and it um it gives authority to
the commissioner of the department of
environmental services um that they can
allocate funding from the new hampshire
volkswagen mitigation trust for electric
school bus pilot
program and um any other additional
federal funding that will become
available and from what we understand
there is a great deal of funding coming
um out for this purpose thank you madam
chair
thank you man i'm sure i i suspect i'm
going to be on the in the minority on
this i
i'm going to vote uh no and the reason
i'm going to vote now is because
i don't think across the nation there
will be a shortage of pilot programs for
electronics or electric school buses
and so anything we might learn from
running our own demo i think we could
learn by just coordinating with other
entities to include some of our own
towns here in new hampshire that i
understand is doing this
the uh
the only reason this uh project i the
only positive reason for doing this
project is is that it's not our money
it's federal money and um and so
occasionally i just feel like i need to
vote to say that federal money is not
free and even if it goes to another
state that's okay
um because i don't know that uh the the
life cycle funding for this pilot
program
will be included because at some point
we're going to have to dispose of the
vehicle we're going to have to dispose
of the battery and i still have never
heard of a good way for these electric
batteries to be um
recycled and
and i i do think so many of these parts
are coming from china that we do not
want to become dependent upon that
supply chain so so i'll be voting now
thank you uh representative wyler
i'm opposed to this war on fossil fuels
because i don't see that the alternative
is is any better
and
we are impoverishing the people of this
country by this push on alternative
fuels which are not successful thank you
thank you are there any other comments
represent waltz
thank you madam chairman as somebody who
drives an electric car i can tell you
that
it's wonderful there's a lot of positive
things to it but one of the problems
with it is when it gets cold the battery
loses some of its life and i would like
to see a school bus trial here in new
hampshire in this climate so that we can
begin to address the issues that come
with the economic climate we're in so i
understand the the thought that maybe
other states would run a pilot program
that we can piggyback off of but unless
it's a state with a climate near ours i
think it's a problem that's not
necessarily going to be addressed
so i'd like to see the pilot program in
our state just so that we can understand
how we deal with this cold weather with
electric vehicles
thank you are there other comments
representing heath thank you madam chair
we're talking about school buses
and we're talking about children
and we're talking about our environment
and we we know that we're seeing climate
change in our world today
i just think we're going to be modeling
the kinds of
new
scientific research that's coming out
and our students will have the
opportunities to participate in it i
just think this is an excellent
opportunity for our state i'm not a
science teacher but if i were a science
teacher i'd be jumping up and down about
this possibility i just think it offers
so much
and it's it's uh the potential for the
learning aspects of all this is great so
i would encourage folks to vote yes on
we're not voting on the pilot we're
voting on the amendment
okay
so we we need to keep that in mind
are there any further comments on the
amendment
yes you may i thank you i just and the
other thing i wanted to say is to the
extent that we need a pilot program
i think we need it to increase our
electrical
electricity generation capacity last
couple of summers we've seen our grid
hit a 90 percent utilization level
excuse me yeah we're not that's not
talking to the amendment please
i i i okay
i'll shut up i'll i'll call on you when
we go to the bill and you can discuss
that
okay
all right all those in favor of
amendment
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
okay uh those opposed
okay how many was that it's uh 12 in
the amendment passes
uh representative heath would you uh
like to make a motion
yes thank you madam chair um i would
like to move um on senate bill 417 as
amended otpa
and i ask for your support do i have a
second
representative murray thank you
represent edwards
you had some comments about the electric
pilot program i i did thank you for uh
giving me a shot to correct myself i i
i
we have so much hope for a clean future
based on use of electricity
what
it seems to me that people are not
paying attention to is where does that
electricity come from it's still going
to have to come from somewhere
um and
i'd like to see us do nukes i'd i would
rather see
i would rather see a pilot project on
electrical generation
then
another way to consume electricity
there's no limit to how we can consume
we need to be producing electricity and
sb
417 as amended
seeing none will the clerk call the role
please
thank you man of chair
representative no
representative
no
representative petri votes no
representative emrick
i'm sorry
representative earth
no representative griffin no
representative edwards no
representation
representative lynn no
representative mooney
no
representative
representative walner
yes
representative norburn yes
president of bucco yes
richard long yes
representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes
president of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative schultz
yes
so
madame share the vote for sb 417
is 10 to 10.
to the house with no recommendation
okay so um
i will need somebody to
write
the
negative
side of this so
someone just jump right up and tell me
i i really have great respect for
representative turcotte and would defer
to his excellent writing style
and i was looking towards uh the
excellent speech that representative
edwards made on the side
i don't care
who it is i will write it
i'll i'll write it if you want i'll i'm
happy to write it okay thank you
representative you don't have a clerk
okay
all right we now move to um
sb 420
establishing an extraordinary need grant
for schools
uh
two zero two two
could i have a motion
[Music]
so moved thank you on the amendment do i
have a second
representative heath thank you very much
um
oh
we had a lot of discussion about what
equalized valuation really meant
because it has
gush
represent heath
because it has all kinds of different
definitions
so
the definition that was in the original
bill
was too broad
and so we
cut it down to where it is just
property and utilities is that right
mickey
i think it's just property and utilities
right
oh yeah
oh well no i'm talking about the
equalized payment yeah
and
as well as uh
the pedo
and um
so there's uh
that's about the extent of
what the uh
seeing none uh
all those in favor of amendment
two zero two two one seven six one
all right we now move
sb420
with an ought to pass
as amended
so
thank you
it's heath
um
this
bill
uh
is came to us
a way of providing
schools
who have very little property value
additional
dollars for their uh children that
receive free and reduced lunch
and
if their evaluation is a million or less
they'll receive 650 per pupil
free and reduced lunch
and if they're between one
million one and
six million
they will receive a grant equal to
.00013
or each dollar of difference between the
equalized valuation and the per pupil
cost
so anyhow and if you're over six million
you don't receive anything six billion
valuation
oh yeah billion
yeah one no
one two three one two three that's
millions
okay
so um
yeah it's not very much
so anyhow when um when the bill came to
us
wanting to raise the uh
amount for special education that was
sent to the schools and that was over 29
million dollars
and we felt that
we could not commit ourselves
to an additional
uh 29 million dollars out of the
education fund in uh
in 2024
so
uh this this is not
a new thought process um
we've worked on it uh several times in
various study committees that we've had
and uh
senator hennessey is uh
is just um
bringing this to us
at this time
representative comments i should not
question about a comment yes
thank you madam chair um
i
i i will be voting against it um
the
total funding on this
was somewhere in the neighborhood of
14.6 million and i apologize i was
writing up the
uh blurb on it and somehow i lost it
and so my percentages may be a little
bit off here but
out of that 14.6 million two cities in
the state would get and i'm going to go
off memory here
somewhere around 25 percent of all that
14.6 million and when i tallied the five
top towns who were going to be receiving
uh it was slightly over 50 it might have
been something like 53. don't hold me to
those numbers
um
and what was even more remarkable was
that over half the towns
at least 50 percent from just looking at
the data we were provided would get
absolutely nothing now i understand the
intent of it but i also understand that
this would be
on top of every other program that
already exists
so in dis
distributing or
as i would say redis redistributing
these funds it appears to be going to
a select few towns i and when you're
talking 14.6 million i just don't think
that is uh
fair and equitable thank you madam chair
quite welcome are there any other
comments representative heath
thank you madam chair um this these
funds were meant to be targeted for
those school districts with the highest
levels of free reduced lunch students
therefore those towns and municipalities
that get less it's because their free
and reduced lunch numbers are so low so
um
i asked for your support for this bill
thank you
there any further
comments seeing none will the clerk
please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh
representative wilder
yes
representative burris
president petrie votes yes
representative earth no
representative griffin
no
representative edwards
representative bean
representative mooney
no
representative turcotte no
yes
president orgrim yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
representative walls yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative schultz
absolutely
and representative america
yes
i don't share the vote on sb 420
water passes amended is
sb 420
uh passes 14 to 6. uh do i have someone
who's going to write a minority report i
will do that madam sure thank you you're
going to be very busy
um i'm already caught up so this will be
the new one okay
thank you
that's ito
yes
thank you
okay
we now move to sb 442 fn
relative to suspension of a vehicle
registration
as a result of evading toll collection
systems
uh
oh yes
representative i move uh uh to pass on
442.
thank you
do i have a second second
represent lynn lynn
would you like to speak to your motion
sure briefly uh basically what this does
is um
allows the department of safety to
terminate registration
for
[Music]
evaders of tolls that
do it frequently and have built up a an
account
of mis
not paying tolls and or administrative
fees
then it would
allow that individual to once those fees
are paid up to get his uh his or her
registration reinstated also closes a
couple of loopholes which they found was
important that there were
ways uh currently that
by transferring titles to family members
or
or within relatives or
people at the same address they avoid
having to pay
the back
back fees and backed holes this and a
couple of the
items in this bill would take care of
those loopholes thank you manager
you're welcome are there any
further comments
seeing none
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you man of chair
representative wilder yes
representative burris
yes
representative petri votes yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative flynn yes representative
mooney yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
represent norgrin yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
representative hatch yes
and walls yes
president of heath yes rosanna murray
yes rosanna schultz yes representative
berger
yes and chair the vote on sb 442 ought
is that consent
uh no
why
uh madam chair there was a cost
associated with the reprogramming uh i
believe it was 250 000 or something like
that
it's not a lot but yes
okay
ten minute break
we have managed to
do an hour in division one an hour in
division two so division three i am
looking forward to
no
you see okay so that's that
yeah it's 5 30
we started on the air
long and i apologize
because
they've changed the locking system
and after five o'clock your keys don't
work
anymore oh no yeah so don't go out if
you expect to get back in
okay
yeah you can get out
but but you can't get back in
so
yeah
so i
it used to be that we could get in but
now you can't
uh i guess that um
you can still get in at park street
you can go that way
and
yeah over there
i hope they change it before committee's
a conference
yeah people are here late hours in
committee's conference i hope we can get
not only that you need to write down the
phone number so they can unlock the door
for you
which we didn't do okay
sorry for the uh delay
relative to the opioid abatement trust
fund
and i will amendment
i will call on representative edwards
uh so madam chair
for
um
for the amendment to 275 i have the most
current version
as
uh 2022
dash 1831 and it should be in everyone's
packets yes
it is okay so so we're talking about
and i i just for reference point um
there's actually 10 things we need to
discuss it looks like seven there are
ten though because of 430 has four four
little right we're talking about the
amendment and so we'll finish by 7 30 i
think do i have a second on the
amendment
yes that was a motion he just
yeah
okay
on eight one eight three one
to the amendment so to the amendment
what the amendment does is in the uh
duties oh that were in the amen in the
primary bill
we uh it said that there would be
support for
public school programs with this these
opioid funds
and so we amended it so that it would
include
their duties would be to support public
and non-public school programs that that
doesn't change the underlying law it
just says that the advisory commission
should be supporting public and
non-public schools
the next thing it does is because the
membership
in the
main bill
changed
the appointment from the governor to
other
members of the public
what we did was we added a sentence into
the bottom of this commission membership
to say that the governor
may remove any non-legislative member
with cause
and that's just in case there's a
problem with one of the members
selling drugs
thank you
are there are there any further comments
questions
all right um
could i have a show of hands
on uh
amendment two zero two two
it looks like it's
everybody
it's all right
okay
so madam chair i would like to move um
the passage of sb 275 ought to pass with
amendment uh two zero two two one eight
three one do i have a second
sure second thank you representative
earth
okay would you like to speak to your
bill
um i i it's describing the amendment i i
talk to most of what we're doing in this
bill it's essentially
changing a little bit on the membership
of this opioid commission and
and
explaining to the commission that their
duties included um
trying to support a range of school
systems
okay
are there any other comments
seeing none will the clerk call the role
thank you very much here
uh
representative wilder yes president
burris
yes
representative petri vocias
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yes representative
lynn yes representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yeah yes
representative walner yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes representative
hatch yes
representative walls yes representative
heath yes representative murray yes yeah
representative schultz yes
and representative berger yes
matter chair the vote on sb 275 out of
passes amended is 20 to zero any
affirmative
sbj 275
is recommended otpa 20 to nothing
we now turn to sb 407
relative to expanding medicaid to
include certain postpartum health
services and making an appropriation
uh i call on uh representative
edwards
so um um i will uh defer to
representative verve to talk on sb407
thank you
sb407
would you like to speak to your motion
yes ma'am
yeah go ahead yes please so sp 407 takes
advantage of the american rescue plan
act provision
allowing new hampshire to extend
medicaid postpartum coverage for up to
12 months after birth
to a narrow segment of women
who currently only receive 60 days of
coverage
this is a group of women whose income is
too great to qualify for medicaid
or expanded medicaid
but without without enough income to
afford insurance coverage
the program extends the federal dollar
match
to this group for five years
the program sun sets when the federal
program ends
and the finance committee agrees with
the bill as it came to us
thank you are there any questions or
comments
seeing none
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you commander chair
representative waller yes president
yes president petrie votes yes
representative erf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yeah representative
lynn yes representative mooney
yes
regina turcotte yes representative
walner yes representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes representative
law yes
representative hatch yes
representative walls yes arizona heath
yes rosanna murray yes
representative schultz yes
it was an umberger yes madam chair of
the vote on sb 407 auto pass is 20 to
zero
in the affirmative thank you sb 40407
otp is recommended otp
20 to 0.
we now turn to sb 416
relative to behavioral health assessment
and treatment of children in out-of-home
placements uh madam chair i i would like
to uh
move on
in the affirmative on 416 and i have an
amendment to offer
okay would you like to um
2022-1786 hotel do i have a second
thank you uh
represent walnut
uh would you like to speak to the
amendment please
yes ma'am the this is a very simple fix
what we did was to clarify
what the intent
uh the actual intent was we didn't
change the intent we added the
phrase
that if a functional behavioral
assessment exists for a student
and then if the iep team has determined
a positive intervention
we we wanted to make sure that the iep
team
knew that if there wasn't a functional
behavioral assessment available at the
time this was not creating a requirement
for one
uh in the uh in the main bill itself
there are other provisions about when
don't talk about the main role i'm
trying not to i'm trying to describe
what i'm not going to talk about thank
you
are there any other questions or
comments on
s beef
as uh yeah the amendment
seeing none could i
have a show of hands to accept the
amendment
okay
uh thank you very much uh now uh
represent edwards you
have a new motion to pass as amended yes
ma'am i move uh uh otpa on sb 416 using
two zero two two one seven eight six
hotel has the amendment
thank you
would you like to speak
please um so so what oh i'm sorry who's
go ahead sorry okay so um what we're
what we're trying to do here
is conduct
a good functional behavioral assessment
earlier on in the process there was a
there has been a gray zone
where um the
localities
had clear obligations of when they
should conduct a functional behavior
assessment but there was a some gray
area about when the state was
responsible for for it so what this bill
did
was it clarified that the state is
responsible for providing a functional
behavior assessment in particular
scenarios
having that
is expected to cost
some money i'm trying to recall the the
exact amount i think the first two years
was something like
1.2 million
but the
belief on the
director ross who who runs this thing
thinks that the benefits of having an
earlier functional behavioral assessment
will have us do
placements earlier and more
appropriately and that and that there's
actually an opportunity to avoid things
like some of the out-of-state placements
saving us
money she thinks this could be a net win
so the the
the finance group looked at it on
whether or not that investment was going
to have a return on it and if it was
adding value and we determined that it
did
thank you are there any other comments
on
seeing none
will the clerk call the roll please
thank you manager chair
arizona weiler yes representative
yes rosanna petrie votes yes
representative irf yes representative
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative lin yes
representative mooney
yes president turcotte
yes representative walner
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes representative
hatch yes representative walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes president schultz yes
and representative ellenberger yes madam
chair of the vote on sb 416 ought to
pass amended is 22-0 in the affirmative
thank you sb 4
recommended otp a
20 to 0.
we now turn to sb 430
relative to health and human services
yes
i will call on represent oh
is there an amendment to this there
there are four actually oh okay
they're they're kind of short only one
of them is controversial so could i uh
have a motion on two zero two two one
zero seven one
uh i i i i'll let representative irf
thank you
uh would you like to speak to your
motion yes ma'am thank you
so this section 29 of this multi-part
hp 430
was
requested a change was requested by the
department of health and human services
the section
relates to reviewing and investigating
all records of the new hampshire
hospital and related and they wanted to
add in the hampshire hospitals a quote
the hampstead hospital or other
state-owned facilities that provide
child inpatient psychiatric treatment
within the state mental health system
and relates to their being able to start
basically working on the contract to
make recommendations regarding pricing
and so on and so forth charge of care
and all that thank you are there any
other comments
yes just procedural i think that the
motion was made on
uh amendment 107
one but i think fourteen seven zero one
seven zero one okay one so i wanted to
make sure for the record sorry thank you
correctly it's me
okay the record's correct thank you uh
representative schultz
okay all those
certainly uh represent everything that
representative earth said that is true
the the downside is if uh we don't pass
this uh
what what we're asking dhhs to do is to
go ahead and begin negotiating
commercial rates before we've closed the
final deal on hampstead and so this
legislation is needed to allow them to
get in front of the process enough so
that if we do close we'll have the
commercial rates negotiated upon opening
so so that's that's why you're seeing
hampstead hospital
this early in the process i recommend
you vote yes
thank you any other comments
seeing none could i have a show of hands
uh
yeah one seven zero one
representative hatch is your hand up yes
what
i thought i thought
yeah
so there are still three more amendments
how do you want to pursue your man okay
we now turn to
[Music]
i'll try to read this one correctly uh
2022-1778
h
representative do you have a motion
so i would move acceptance of
amendment two zero two two one seven
seven eight h to hb four three zero sp
four
three zero sorry uh and i'll second that
okay thank you
uh would you like to speak to your
motion
so this
uh amendment uh changes or amends
section three of this multi-part bill
that section is developing a pilot
program to provide services for
individuals with developmental
disabilities between 18 and 21 years of
age who are enrolled in school and
determined eligible for services that
are not the responsibility of a local
education agency another state agency or
another division of the part department
participation in the program should be
limited to not more than 20 eligible
individuals the only thing we changed in
this section was allowing the funds to
lapse as is typically the case
thank mountain chair
is there anything else in the uh
remainder of the amendment
well the amendment's huge but it's
basically replacing something that's
already in the bill the only thing that
we replaced was literally we took out
the words and the funds shall be
non-lapsing okay so everything else
that's here was in the original bill as
approved by the policy committee that
came to us okay
all right thank you
seeing none i will ask all those in
so so we have another amendment uh
if you'll hang on just a moment please
okay
all right uh
this is amendment
2022-1823
[Music]
i believe we're talking about 1783
the there there is also a one eight two
three but it's uh subsequent to this one
i believe oh i thought that was part of
that last one
all right
uh this is uh one seven eight three so i
would move
amendment two zero two two one seven
eight three h to
uh s b four thirty do i have a second
second
thank you
um
yes ma'am
i'd love to speak to it i thought so
so this
deletes section six of the multi-part
sp430
that section
was
changing the reporting that dhhs does
regarding related to the medicaid family
planning services annual report and it
essentially removed the annual report
so by deleting it we are effectively
leaving the annual report
of the medicaid family planning services
in place
okay are there any further comments on
amendment
seeing none all those in favor please
opposed
all right now i can move to amendment
2022-1823h
is this you again rip center no this
one's mine okay representative edwards
uh i would like to um
move um
passage of two zero two two one eight
two three second thank you and i'd like
to speak to that yes you may
um
now i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna back up and
give a little bit of background on this
because uh the background i think is
relevant um
this this language may look familiar to
you all because
this language is identical all the way
down to the final comma
to
house bill one zero four four
one zero four four was passed by the
house sent to the senate the senate took
it and put it into interim study
it's become a topic of interest
that the house would like to discuss
this in a committee a conference and so
we've been asked to
take another run up the hill on this
now
i wasn't sure what the procedures were
so it
by the time i asked the clerk and the
clerk could get back to me
i had eaten two of the three days the
committee had to work on it and so
unfortunately
our blue team colleagues
did not get a chance to see this until
yesterday and so what i promised
the ranking member was that
i would make sure that she had plenty of
opportunity to weigh in on any concerns
that she has um
so but but what does it do first and
then we can talk about why it's bad but
what it does first is uh
health facilities that are membership
based or
on predicated on a direct payment
business model
from having
to meet the requirement to provide
services to all persons so so it it it
does not become a
does not like we do with our other
facilities does not require them to
participate in sort of an urgent care
setting
um
uh and
and so
some concerns were raised that
this bill
would put pressure on our critical care
facilities because these
uh different the this group of
facilities that operate in a different
business model
may have
unfair competitive advantage that could
cause our critical care facilities to to
go belly up and we don't no one wants
that no one wants that so so i i checked
and there there is still that provision
in
new hampshire law that
no competitive facilities
for service can operate within 15 miles
unless it's permitted by the state i'm
unaware of any being permitted by the
state and because this is a new business
model that we're trying to grow some of
us are trying to grow as an alternative
to uh the fee for service systems
um we we wanted to exempt them
from having to treat people who are not
in their membership or is not are not
enrolled in their direct pay method
so so i i i think this is a good thing
representative mclean introduced it in
the house and passed the house
and with that um
if
uh i guess representative weiler you're
the acting chair could
could we allow representative walner
with the time she wants to talk to this
president wallner is recognized
well
i do have a lot of concerns about this
these providers will not be required
like all of our other health care
providers to accept
medicaid
and
this
really will leave could leave a burden
on
our
most of the hospitals that
have spoken to us
oppose this this piece of legislation
and
i
am concerned about the department of
health and human services
being able to
uh really monitor this and
they they do do the licensing
of healthcare facilities and i think
this is going to
be a whole new area that they are going
to have to be
um
licensing so i'm concerned about i'm
certain one thing that's very concerning
is the quick turnaround time and the
time that the
hospital the time that the department
would need
to really be able to license this type
of facility
i think it sets up a very dangerous
precedent to be um
setting up a group of health care
providers who will not have to accept
medicaid
eligible clients and
i think it's something that
we need to give
a lot of thought to
and
as
chairman
edward said this sort of came in at the
last minute though it was a bill that
passed
past the house which is now in the
senate so i assume that there will be
ample opportunity to keep discussing it
any other comments
i have one and i said it at the uh
division work session
all these other hospitals that get a
break because they have emergency rooms
they don't pay property taxes they don't
pay meals and rooms taxes they don't pay
business profits tax
so
they get a big break worth millions of
dollars and in return we expect them to
hold emergency
uh services available for anybody that
walks in and
it isn't as if they they do treatment
for xero because they all get medicaid
everybody they treat if they're not
getting medicaid they're getting
medicare or private insurance so
in these
hospitals that we speak of that we're
newly allowing
end up paying all the taxes so
i think there's a balance in my mind
there to
to what what we require of the others
and the fact that they don't want
competition
they're forgetting all the breaks we
give them that should be helping them to
pay for the care that they call free but
is always charged to medicaid
anybody else
representative
hatch
um thank you mr chair i'm i just um this
isn't my area
of endeavor but
i have worked with hospitals in the past
and our non-profit hospitals
though they may not pay property taxes
and the bet and a few other taxes they
do add to the community tremendously and
and you might find a few
non-proprietary places
pay in lieu of taxes to local
communities and they help support the
tax base in that community
tremendously they also
treat
people
you say they charge for and charge
yearly maybe they do but they also
treat people without charging for it
they also give free care and we know
this very well because
every year or every budget cycle we look
at uncompensated care and that's exactly
what that is it's these institutions
brought these people in
and gave them care
without any reimbursement for doing so
where your propriety hospital
isn't required to do that so what
happens is um in the
my concern and and that's above my pay
rate to figure this out exactly and i
think maybe this is why um maybe our hhs
department needs to
time to figure this out is there's only
so many dollars there for reimbursement
period and there's only so many dollars
that our non-proprietary hospitals get
now one thing they depend on is i have
private insurance
my insurance pays my local hospital
full tilt
all right i may have a copay on a phil
few but they pay him full tilt
and why that is important is it allows
anascoggin valley hospital
to have the resources
to stay within the community pay the
personnel and provide this very
necessary care to people that do not
have insurance and do not have the
resources to pay for it they die
it sounds dramatic but i've seen it
firsthand it's the real deal
my sons were emts
more than once they've taken people with
no resources
up to our local hospitals they got the
care they needed and why did they get
that care
again what i just stated is
my insurance company for our care pays
the full boat and it gives the hospital
those resources so let's think about
what happens
to
the people that no longer maybe would go
to anderscoggin or would they would go
to
one of these non uh these proprietary
hospitals that are often kind of glitzy
and nice and chooses to go there to get
their care
say i do
all right
my local hospital will get a hell of a
lot less money
on a given year that is
important to them to provide the care
they pry provide because the hospital
down here that might have a little
better room for me or
whatever um that i go to
gets the money that
they used to utilize to provide the care
so it's it's complicated
it's deep and it's way beyond me to
figure out but i know what i just stated
is absolute and i do know of areas
where these types of hospitals
went into
and the ones that provide the free care
whatever that is
or provide the community the needed
services that it needs
um so people maybe don't die so often on
the street
will not survive and that's real stuff
that's real stuff and i think we should
allow some time to figure this out thank
you mr chair
anyone else representative lynn yes this
is really a question i would i guess i
would direct it to either representative
walner or representative edwards this
this is obviously not my area but
one of the things that i think you both
sort of mentioned that kind of concerns
me is that this
kind of came up on relatively short
notice that there wasn't a lot of time
to sort of think about this and and you
know get a lot of input and
so i have some concern about that i i
guess
one of the things that you you mentioned
representative edwards that i think i
sort of had in the back of my mind but i
had forgotten about is apparently
there's still
we don't have a certificate of need
board anymore but there's still this
15-mile thing
i i guess i
you know i wonder how much actual
protection that provides in the sense
that at 15 you know does that really
make much of a difference in people in
you know when it was i guess to me of
whether a doctor's office was in 15
miles or 25 miles of wind it wouldn't
make that much difference to me i would
think but
so i guess what i'm just saying is that
may be something that needs
further
further explanation in terms of its
implications for this and then the last
thing that i have is am i understanding
from this
um from this proposal
that
the the the the uh
the facilities that would be uh where it
says the the facilities that are covered
by the unless clause
that they would not have any obligation
to provide services even in an emergency
situation in other words there was a gun
shot somebody came in with a gunshot
wound could they just say you know sorry
we don't uh
president edwards you wish to answer so
i i heard i heard two questions i heard
a question about has there been
sufficient time to vet this and i've
heard uh you do a desire to hear more
about the urgent care setting
on the first point
i would just remind
everyone that this bill as hb
went through the policy committee and
passed and so that policy committee said
this is good and not just the policy
committee but the entire house then
subsequently took a vote on it passed it
and sent it over to the senate
so
while it is true that division three
didn't have much time to look at it as
i'm
often reminded we don't do policy we
just do money
all right and so
so this is the policy of the policy
committee
and it it it doesn't have
um
a direct obvious
impact on general funds so
so it's kind of in the category of of
you know
approve it because it's outside of our
financial purview
the other thing
as you're talking about the urgent care
setting
some of these institutions can just be
concierge kind of eight to five places
and and they aren't
necessarily open 24 by seven so so the
point of of this model
is to be flexible and adaptable to the
market
and and see if there's an alternative
way of delivering care that consumer
choice will then go select
so a lot of the concerns i hear about
this because i'm a simple person i i
kind of summarize it is that we're
consider we're concerned about what
consumers may choose if we allow them to
and as i recall we were promised that if
we liked our health insurance if we
liked our doctor we could keep them
so now here's an opportunity to make
good on that promise from 10 years ago
by creating a choice in the market that
representative
so i guess if
this is more of a process
statement
i guess if you liked house bill 1044 you
had an opportunity to vote on it
whenever it was a couple weeks ago a few
weeks ago
and it's over in the senate
and that's the process
it's a paul it was strictly a policy
bill and it went straight to the floor
and had a vote on the policy and it's
over there and if you like that policy
it passed and it's on its way to the
senate
but before us we have
a bill
that
contains a lot of really important
pieces of legislation the department has
been working on this bill
during this whole session
and if you look and we read through the
bill you'll see
there's a variety of things in this bill
that need to happen it's a very
important piece of legislation
and i feel it is really an abuse of the
process
to bring in a bill a stand-alone bill
and put it into
a bill that is so important to the
department of health and human services
and it certainly isn't something that
they have asked for need or want
it'll probably only end up causing them
a lot of
a lot of grief to tell you the truth
and for that reason i i really feel it's
it is really
outside of the finance committee's
jurisdiction to be adding
this piece which is strictly policy
if if there was a financial
part of this i might understand how it
would fit but i can't even make a
finding there's not even a financial
argument here
um so i urge you not to
pass this amendment i do want to remind
all of you
and all of you live in communities that
have
hospitals or you use hospitals that are
close to your community
how important your hospital is and the
great benefits they provide to us
and you're right
if i have no money at all
and i fall down and break my leg
as i leave the state house i can go
right up to concord hospital emergency
room and they will take care of me
because that's their obligation the
state says you have to do that now we're
setting up a group of providers who
won't have to do that
yes representative
thank you and i apologize for my
ignorance on on the legislative
procedure on this but here's my question
if we
um
reject this amendment
does
what's the implica can that issue
of whether it should be it should be in
or out
be raised in a conference committee or
if we take it if we sort of reject this
is that the end of it it cannot be
raised in a conference committee
it if we rejected it will not be part of
senate bill 430
and the fact that they've gone to
interim study on 1044
doesn't even allow for a committee
conference to bring the subject up
someone could try it in the committee a
conference bringing this up again but
i don't know what the chances would be
but it's always possible it could be
introduced
but i would like to say that there's
there's 26 hospitals in this state
and in the
30 years i've been watching this they
have not allowed any competition one of
the reasons we got rid of the um
certificate of need
was
they would do everything in their power
to keep
any new medical facility from opening up
and then some they put out a business
that were clinics
and
they they really abused their power in
my mind and as i said they're getting a
lot of breaks and taxes in order to pay
for all the services that we think
they're giving away but they also get
disproportionate share and all those
other things i'd like to see more
competition in this health field and i
think by passing this we could do that
anybody else
representative
i'm not quite sure if
the your question was exactly answered
correct i believe you asked as if this
was put into the bill if it could be
addressed further when we got to a
committee conference
i believe the answer to that would be
yes
thank you thank you appreciate it
alternatively if it's not put in it's
what representative weiler said it's a
dead letter
right
anyone else
all right we're we're ready to have a
vote on
amendment number one eight two three if
you're in favor of that please raise
there are only 20 people here
all right let's
all right we'll do it again
all in favor of adopting this amendment
one two three four five six seven
eight
ten okay
all right again
all opposed
one two three four
so at this time uh madam chair just a
moment please
we have a another amendment
1871.
that's a different bill oh
yeah that's 4.59 i'm sorry i think we're
done with the amendments okay excuse me
i can't read
of dyslexia and i can't read so i'm
having a
heck of a time i've done well yeah
okay uh
i think we need an otp a
motion yes ma'am my emotion otpa with
the three amendments that passed uh
ending in one seven zero one one seven
seven eight one seven eight three
and not including the last one one eight
two three
second
okay i have a uh
would you like to speak to your motion
representative edwards
uh no ma'am because there's 50 parts to
430 and uh and basically it's
that part was vetted in 11 hours by hhs
and so i'm going to take them at their
word
okay
is there anyone else that would like to
uh represent mooney thank you madam
chair uh just to add i was actually
substituting on health and human
services the day this was introduced i
got a real good overview sat there for
11 hours and i will definitely be voting
ought to pass with amendments
thank you okay anyone else
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you madam chair uh
you have all the amendments down there
representative wilder yes representative
uh
the burst yes there was in a petri votes
yes representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yeah representative
lynn yes rosanna mooney
yes it was intercourse yes
arizona walner
yes
arizona northern yes rosanna bucco yes
representative long yes representative
hatch yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray yes
representative schultz yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote on senate bill 430
ought to pass with amendments
1701 1778 1783 passes
thank you
uh sb 430
octopass as amended
uh 20 to 0.
we now turn to sb 444
i
i need a motion representative edwards
uh madam chair i'll look to
representative walner to offer her
i move that uh
senate bill 444
fn be ought to pass second
representative earth second
representative walner would you like to
speak to your amendment
or to your amendment to the bill to the
bill
this bill
is about children
who have adverse childhood
experiences and the bill
would
provide services for those children and
their families
there are a lot of programs that have
been designed to help those families or
when the children are very young this
bill really deals with children under
the age of six
working with their families and with the
children it does have an appropriation
in it of uh
2.7 and a half 2.75
million dollars so um
the with that with those funds there
will be a pilot program
that will support children age zero to
eight
with um
who have been exposed to adverse
childhood events and those kinds of
experiences are things like children who
are born of um
drug addicted parents or
[Music]
alcoholism or children who very early
have been abused or neglected in their
family
so it provide will provide services for
seven hundred thousand dollars to start
to build a workforce
around parent-child psychotherapy
right now there's very few people
working in this field and this will help
to build that field
500 000 will be to support uh children's
behavioral health providers
um and training them
and a million dollars will be spent um
to support family resource centers and
those are those are places where
families can go to get
assistance um
it takes it's all all families can use
them
families with children who are having
difficulties and have
had
bad experiences in early childhood
really benefit from these programs so
hope you'll support it thank you are
there any other comments
representative
thank you madam chair i i believe the
actual number is
1.7 million dollars i think two of the
four programs were actually removed
before it got to us
but more importantly all of these funds
are american
thank you
either the two representatives
um mentions arpa funds
and um
should opera funds uh run out at some
point in the future for this program
does this program it notes that it is a
pilot program
is there a drop dead date on this
program
well there's only
sorry there's only one year of funding
in this
piece of legislation so
if they wanted to continue if there was
um if the pilot was successful and they
wanted to continue the program it would
have to be included in the next budget
the next biennium budget so this doesn't
go past the
represent them to bears thank you madam
chair uh i was reading the methodology
and it says if the op funds are not
available any other federal funds may be
used
it doesn't have to be specific to a
certain
like health related or something not
just any in general is it
is that legal
well i imagine they would have to use
funds that the federal government had
set aside for this
type of program they wouldn't be able to
use highway funds or well
i was confused thank you because this is
any
you know federal funds i think the
health department of health and human
services would have to look into the
funds that would be available for this
type of program okay thank you
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you madam chair representative
weiler yes
representative
yes president petrie votes yes
representative irf yes representative
griffin yes representative edwards yes
representative bean representative lynn
no
representative mooney yes
arizona turcotte no
representative walner
yes
it was in norgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative long yes
arizona hatch yes
representative walsh yes
version of heath yes
representative murray yes rosanna
schultz yes arizona
yes
madam chair the vote for sb 444 ought to
pass is 18 to 2 any affirmative
thank you ssb 444.
otp and for the vote of 18 to 2.
we now turn to sb
fn
relative to sununu use service center
operations and a replacement
secure facility
uh
representative irf would you like to
make
a motion
yes madam chair i'd like to move sp 458
thank you uh
uh would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair so now
division three voted six to one to adopt
the children and family law policy
committee recommendation in full it
passed the house on a 244 to 88 vote
it contains two parts
first it added hb 254 which passed the
house on a 264 to 87 vote
hb 254 continues the legislature's long
standing philosophy of reducing the
types of criminal activities for which
commitment to the
sununu center is possible in favor of
treating as many of these children as
possible in the community
second the bill provides for a new
six-bed replacement facility for the
sununu center
division iii looked to the department of
health and human services for guidance
on the cost of construction of a six-bed
facility
but we're told the time frame was too
short to address this
much of the sb 458 discussion in the
division
centered around the six-bed replacement
facility for the sonuna center put forth
by the policy committee
director ribsum related how during his
tenure which i believe is four or five
years
the census at the sununu center has
decreased from something over 70 when he
arrived to 11 as of march 24th of this
year
he also related that the substantial
investment new hampshire is making in
the system of care for youth should
continue this downward trend over the
next four to five years
as younger miners are drawn into the
system at a younger age when the system
is better able to impact their lives and
their environment
this is likely to bring the census down
into the lower end of the ranges being
discussed over this time period
this points to the need for us to be
careful
not to invest dollars in an overly large
facility
given the downward trend and need for a
sununu-style lockdown facility over the
past few years
the anticipated effect of hb 254
and the anticipated continuation of this
trend as the system of care continues to
build out we should be looking to the
future and not the present and making
determinations about what to build as a
replacement
the house policy committee allowed for
the same final completion date as the
senate
this is fully four years from now
in the 2026 time frame a bed a six-bed
facility is realistic
this would lower the cost of
construction relative to a larger
facility
and lower the staffing costs somewhat
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any questions or
comments
uh representative erf
sorry represent edwards the other one
yeah the other one uh okay so i'm the
only one that voted against us in
division three and i voted against it
because uh i i
did not hear the department say that six
was achievable uh
i heard that on hope and aspiration and
belief that the system of care so that
we are building out but is not yet
currently proven uh throughout
is uh it gives us the assurance we need
to go from our
data
to
six beds
so what does our data tell us uh our
data tells us
that um the census at the sununu center
is somewhere between 10
14 18 depending on the kind of the
monthly blip
and uh and and
ignoring
that data a number six was picked out of
the air
if you listen to the exec session by
children and family law the chairman
basically
said
as much
that
let's just make it six and then let
finance negotiate it up from there
and so uh i read that as an abdication
of our responsibility
to plan effectively to communicate
clearly to the senate what we think
and it's an abdication of our
responsibility to public safety because
if we don't have the capacity to store
not store but to
house
these
people these young people
in a secure environment when they need
it
then we're going to be endangering the
public safety so before i am comfortable
doing that i would want to walk through
the the the plan i would want to know
when these other
catcher's mitts are going to be
available so that they
that that these youth do not need to be
uh locked
uh in the into the sununu-like center so
i
in the last two years this this is this
is the low point of the term for me
having this bill come out this way i'm
thank you for your comments are there
any other comments uh representative
lynn yes um thank you madam chair
i have to say respectfully that i really
think this bill is not ready for prime
time i
as you know i made my pitch on the floor
uh with with uh both 254 and this and
and the the part of
of uh this bill that essentially added
254 and i would note representative
erf mentioned the the various votes um
in the in the vote
um
the last time that this bill was up the
vote um you know at least in in my
caucus was uh eight uh i over eighty
percent of the people in my caucus
agreed with with my position on the bill
no no that's that's uh
the that doesn't mean the but the bill
didn't pass but i would raise a couple
of things that i i think are i hope
you'll consider because i think they're
very important
first of all as i said before this
adopting this bill will make us as far
as i know will make us the only state in
the country that says that a a minor can
never be committed
uh to a juvenile facility
for a property related crime no matter
how serious how much property is taken
how much property is damaged
and incidentally on that the one of the
one of the things i hope you'll think
about
i went to the division three
um uh hearing on this and and as you
know this bill this the 254 section of
this bill says a jew
a minor can never be committed for a
misdemeanor
well lo and behold at that hearing one
of the people from the disabilities
rights center this is not someone who
normally i'm on the same wavelength with
but one of the people from the
disabilities rights center said
please don't make this only felonies
because if if
if it has to be a felony for somebody to
be committed what's going to happen is
prosecutors and judges are going to make
something that might
be negotiated down to a misdemeanor
they're going to treat it as a felony if
that's the only way that somebody can be
committed and they believe that there
needs to be a commitment this wasn't
this you know this wasn't a particular
argument of mine it was an argument
of the disabilities rights center
despite the fact that i lost on the
floor as i said before i voted for the
bill the basic bill itself because i
believed that we really did need to do
something about the sununu center i was
and i was thinking that you know there
would be some there would be
some negotiation
before this committee of having a uh
of of exactly how many beds it should be
something more than six
but it didn't turn out that way i would
just note finally the final commit
point i would make is my recollection is
consistent with representative edwards
in terms of what mr ribson said about a
six bed facility and i would note in
support of my recollection being correct
that after the committee took its vote
as i was sitting in the back as mr
ribson was lead was leaving he turned to
me and said this is nuts
um so for all of those reasons i simply
seeing none oh i'm sorry represent
walnut i just want to add one
small thing but it's not really small
but it's just something to for us all to
remember that
we have been working on building out the
system of care
and
right now we have
in contract
and we learned this from mr ribson
over 400 beds
in group homes at all different levels
in the state
but presently there's probably only 300
between 280 and 320 children in those
beds so we do have capacity
in
our group homes to
provide
living situations residential care for
children who
do not need to be at the sununu center
but do need residential care so there is
capacity and yes mr ribson said they're
having hard time hiring
and
their
sununu center is having a hard time
hiring too everybody's having a hard
time hiring so that's
um but we do have a contract with about
representative edwards
thank you i i just i would like i would
ask representative walner if she could
clarify her use of the word all
when you said that all of the
residents at sununu could be put into
i think you did you said all
that there's capacity for all of the
well okay i won't ask you what you said
because i apparently i'm just getting it
wrong but what i think i heard
is that
we could choose as an option to move
sununu kids into group homes and i think
that there's a
security distinction
level three level four level five and
what sununu is represents a level five
security environment where they they
have
all the you know
double security and cameras and all of
that uh and the best we have in a group
home situation is a level four
so so if we have an excess of six kids
that need level five security and we
move them into a level four
that is the exact threat to public
i did think i heard representative
representative
director rip some say that often
children leave the sununu center and go
into group homes
so the a lot of the goal is to try to
move
to move
the kids out of the sununu center and
into
maybe they go into a level four or three
level three group home so that we try to
move them out into the community as
quick as we can so you having a small
facility for those most serious
violent
children that's the way
okay representative edwards
so
so i agree with you that the goal is to
do a step down into less secure
environments but my point remains if
there is a seventh kid that needs level
five we don't have an answer for that
seventh kid
so
anytime you move that incremental
individual
from
needing level five into a lower level of
security
you're you're adding public safety risk
in the equation that that that's all i'm
saying and you're absolutely right we
want to step these down kids down we
want them to feel
warmth and love and
but some of some of these kids are just
not
okay are there any further comments
i have a question of uh representative
edwards certainly uh where do you stand
to me talking to mike
i i assume that's a joke i i am
absolutely uh
i'm a
here's the problem
where do that's a really great question
where am i now
because we failed to plan and because
this is the only vehicle to continue the
planning process
we are in a
god-awful place where we have to pass
this to keep the process going if we
kill this then
there is no bill
and there is no plan to handle
what happens because the current law
says sununu closes at the end of march
um and there's no plan other than this
plan
which is why this plan was so important
and and
it's so devastating that we failed to do
it right
so
ironically i hope you all vote yes but
yes may i make just one one other
comment and i want to thank
representative walsh for this because i
i had i had completely i don't think i'm
i'm not sure i really
uh had focused on this and i certainly
didn't didn't understand it until she
brought it to my attention but if it's
true as i as i'm sure it is that that
under the was it the prison rape
elimination act uh
uh even an adult
even an adult i mean sorry even someone
that is treated as as an adult for
purposes of of criminal prosecution if
they're if they're convicted they cannot
serve their sentence in an adult
facility they need to go to a juvenile
unless unless they're separate
separate uh which as i understand it
the new hampshire state prison doesn't
have
right so so stop and think about this
what we're saying here is
that six
the number of people
under 18 who will be serving a sentence
for any crime for any crime either as an
adult
or the crimes that are that under under
the 254 aspect of this would be limited
for which a minor might be committed are
going to be six people for the whole
state
six people
it seems to me just on its face
that is that is
completely unrealistic i mean i if
they're you know the idea that there
would be
six that only six people under the age
of of uh of 18 would be serving some
kind of a sentence for and you know
let's assume we limit it to very violent
offenders only six
wow
i'm i'm that's very surprising to me
thank you very much
are there any other comments
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
thank you madam chair
president weiler yes or not to pass
representative petrie votes no
representative edwards no
representative lynn now
representative walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes represents long
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative schultz yes represent
madam chair of the vote on sb 458
is auto pass
13 to
7.
on a vote of 13 to 7 sb
passes
we now turn to
and we have
relative to healthcare facility
workplace violence prevention program
and we have an amendment
it's amendment
1871 h
represent earth
uh man i'm sure that's my amendment okay
i uh i move um
second by representative erf
well first this has nothing to do with
the sununu center
so
that's good
this bill
uh came to us from the house
uh it basically did a a few things in it
it established
a commission to study workplace
violence and a limited set of health
care environments
it set up a reporting system that
included some confidentiality provisions
is this what the amendment is discussing
we touched on all of these in the
amendment so so every every topic i've
just said gets is in this amendment okay
fine so it's not i mean
we're talking about the amendment not
the bill i i'm trying to okay please
okay
so um
so it came it came that way it
it
the the uh
and then it has a very simple
over simple definition in it so
um what we did was um we we looked at it
and we agreed that
uh with the hospital systems and the and
the nurses that workplace violence in
these settings uh is a very real problem
what we heard was that
uh the hospitals and the nurses have all
in in some of the urgent care settings
have have all sort of agreed finally
after four or five years of batting us
around that they wanted to do something
so so uh so what we did was we respected
that with this amendment that we're
going to um
have these programs
but
uh rather than have them mandatory
[Music]
with a of a coercive aspect of things
like fines
we modified it to keep it still
compulsory for their participation but
we removed the fines in this amendment
we
went into the confidentiality part of
the reporting and in it we
made sure that none of the that there
was no protection
for the commission when they were
talking about personally identifiable
information
um so so we kept personally identifiable
information out of the commission
dialogue
they could introduce it you know if
there was a police report that the
and we removed and from the health
facilities we we removed the state from
being a compulsory member
we did keep the
ceo or or her
designee
as a member of
the commission itself
so because our new hampshire
hospital has
a really
good
workplace violence program that's worthy
of emulation
so so we're not mandating they
participate in the program but we are
putting um that ceo or designee onto the
board so that it's easier to share and
so that the state has some direct
communication with this commission
so um
we
took the workplace violence definition
which originally included as as
workplace violence if somebody said
we verbally abused another person
but the recipient
felt absolutely no stress
that was going to be categorized as
workplace violence and so we want we
wanted to get real numbers and so we
split out the distinction between things
that we would agree is workplace
violence violence
uh and from another category called
harsh words
and uh and so we want the reporting to
be distinct so that we we actually know
the scope of the problem
so so i guess uh in summary
um we we we retained
the com the kind of the compulsory
nature
of the commission and the programs
um with the exception of exempting
state facilities and any urgent care
centers that have less than three
centers in their constellation
we
modified and i think improved the data
privacy aspect of the bill we removed
the penalties and since we were removing
a stick to use against the non-compliant
ones we created a carrot by having the
department maintain a website where
everyone's
active participation would be listed and
that way if say
boondoggle
hospital
should be participating and doesn't then
there would be regular uh regular
ability to report that they're inactive
or not participating and then the nurses
and in the community can get upset at
them instead of having the commissioner
find them
so um so we we voted this out at
division three this morning it took a
little while to get the
the amendment put together
um i i think it's fair to say that both
the nurses association and hospitals
association
believe that this is an acceptable bill
they've been trying for three or four
years to get this going this will get it
going
some of the main architecture things
that they wanted are preserved but we we
softened the edges of the coercive
aspects of the bill
so um
with that i'll i'll stop and take
questions if there are any are there any
other comments questions
representative lin yes um uh thank you
and thank you representatives for taking
my question i i was uh
in for at least part of the division
three hearing on this because i was
waiting for 458
yesterday or the day before whenever it
was
and you um raised a number of questions
to witnesses at the at the hearing
about as i understood it anyway about
why
was it necessary to have
to have this be other than completely
voluntary and and i thought those were
very good questions and i'm not sure i
really heard particularly good answers
from the witnesses um and so i guess i
would pose the question again why all of
this sounds like it's very it's it's
very important and a very good thing to
happen
but
why can't uh hospitals just do it on
their own
i i think that's an excellent question i
don't think i heard really an adequate
answer to the question but to be fair to
the process and the people who
participated in it
uh i i it's it's really important that
this program get established
they they the the the nurses the work
staff they're really crying out that
they want this program it's been three
or four years of trying to get it going
without success
it it it it's it's it's the process of
having this legislation that is really
puts the stake in the ground that it
shall happen
and i
think that as a philosophical matter if
they all really want to do it it could
be more voluntary than what we left it
i i made
some trade-off decisions as in the
drafting of this
to go ahead and leave
the compulsory nature of the commission
and the program in place
but removing the active penalties other
than what could be brought to bear by
community pressure through the use of
the website
and and
to that it's more compulsory than i'm
comfortable with but uh but i think when
you're making sausage
uh this is a reasonable accommodation
thank you
are there any further questions uh
thank you madam chair i believe
representative norgren has had her hand
up so i'll give you her
okay representative yeah no i just
wanted to compliment the chair in
division three in particular i think
this was a scary process that we started
on i think the hospital association a
lot of those
uh
stakeholders were worried what we were
going to come up with but in the end the
hospital association and the people some
of them who were in the audience today
agreed with it i think
the issue
the primary issue i think was the
agreement on making it mandatory and not
voluntary because we felt if one
hospital dropped out then it wasn't a
worthwhile process
but i think the product we ended up with
was agreeable to all parties which i
think was a huge accomplishment
thank you representative mooney
thank you madam chair at one point this
bill had a warrantless arrest provision
i just want to confirm that is still no
longer part of your amendment you're
introducing today so so
just to back up a little bit
the warrantless arrest component of this
was removed by hhs in the house before
it came to us there was no appetite for
adding it back because
the belief i think of the house and
certainly
most of the division three my guess is
is that um
if if there are issues with warrantless
arrests in new hampshire it's bigger
than the hospital system and so it
really ought to be addressed as a more
comprehensive thing by the criminal
justice or judiciary and not by hhs so
we did not attempt to bring that back in
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair i'm going to echo a little bit of
what representative lin asked and that
is
i i'm baffled by the the mandatory
uh nature of the bill
uh
the hospital association of course i
wasn't in the hearings but the if the
hospital association the nurse
association and everybody involved is in
favor of this my question would be why
hasn't anything been done over the last
three four years or whatever the time
frame um i
i think making this a mandatory
with all the reporting requirements and
everything that goes along with us i i
think it just for me it goes a little
bit too far thank you madam sure
would someone like to answer that
question
well representative edwards
thank you um
i think
our health care system has been under
tremendous stress in the last couple of
three years and so
um and i i wouldn't be surprised if the
very things that were stressing the
health care system and distracting the
executives and others
uh
also was contributing to an increase in
violence right
so um so we did put a repeal in this at
10 years um so that if if this bill
isn't really necessary it'll age itself
out
um
so why didn't the health care system
take care of this i think maybe because
uh it's hard to organize a bunch of cats
and get them to agree to things and and
if nothing else by putting it into a law
into a framework there's something that
all of them could look at instead of
constantly wrestling with each other on
different perspectives of what it should
look like this at least gives them that
framework could it have been voluntary i
believe it could have been but
it you know at the end of the day i i
wanted to make sure that we came up with
a program and a commission
um and and we can revise and extend this
legislation based on our experience we
one of the things that's in the
amendment i should maybe should have
mentioned was we introduced the fact
that the commission has a reporting
relationship with
the joint
um
i'm on the darn thing the joint uh hhs
oversight committee
it had been
that the commissioner
could only act to make changes in the
program or in the law
if she had the cons advice and consent
of the commission
so we stripped out the consent part
and we inserted um
hhs so we should be getting the annual
reports we should be able to monitor
this
um
if if
if the law needs to change we can change
it but this was let's at least get the
canoe in the water and let people start
thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
this is uh hb
yep all those in favor of amendment one
eight
okay now i need a motion of octopus man
i'm sure i'd like to move uh ought to
pass with amendment on sb 459 using
amendment
2022-1871 hotel second
is there any further discussion on the
bill
good seeing none
now the clerk can call the roll
second try yeah
okay this is uh senate bill 459 auto
pass as amended
representative weiler yes
resenator burrish yes
representative petri voces
representative erf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney
yes
representative
no
president orgrim
version bucco
represents long
representative hatch yes
arizona walls
president heath yes
representative murray
representative schultz
representative hamburger yes
madam chair the vote on sb 459 overpass
is amended as 18 an affirmative and two
in the negative will there be a minority
report
okay thank you
uh
sb
459 otpa passes 18 to 2.
okay
uh the last time i checked with janet
hatch
waltz
turcotte
walner
okay
these are
those four were all minority reports
that
janet had not received i said the last
okay
so represent representative you may go
home
uh madam
shearer yeah yes you know i was gonna um
this is really a question to
representative edwards um
i'm i'm sort of in the middle of
drafting a minority report on f on 458
if you're if you've already done it
that's fine uh representative edwards
has already done
a minority report on 458. oh okay
correct oh all right that's fine
thank you okay i
i thank you all
and uh janet well thank you all when you
get your reports in
so please
you